like the thing is is people don't
appreciate that this is like we're in a
[Music]
war Diamond
hand infinite means infinite infinite
risk infinite reward I'm sure my
portfolio looks a lot of red but I'm in
it for the long haul Lambos or Wendy's
I'm going to get my
tendies there are tens of thousands of
hours of video and text in existence all
seeking to explain what exactly happened
with GameStop in January 2021 there are
explainer videos unhinged rants
Congressional hearings and Netflix
produced documentaries all trying to
tell the story of this one weird moment
in time and what it might mean what it
says about us our society and our
economy the common version is that a
band of Plucky retail investors put the
screws to hedge fund Melvin C capital in
a historic short squeeze an
unprecedented win for the little guy the
nuanced read is that it was a Confluence
of once in a generation social forces a
short squeeze but also a fomo fueled
social media phenomenon where just as
many regular folk got wrecked as made
off like Bandits that however is merely
where our story starts this is a story
about what happened next this is a story
about Finance social media conspiracy
theories gambling mortal men elevated to
mythological figures and a mountain of
human suffering built of a thousand
little lies this is financial
[Music]
advice
wind is
BL Wind and The
Chill subjects relating to exchange
practices have been characterized by
greater differences of opinion than that
of Short Selling but what is a short
sale a short sale involves borrowing an
asset selling it at current market value
and then returning it later ideally at a
lower price than when it was sold but
simply it's selling borrowed Goods to
buy back at a profit there are some
things that we need to caveat right off
the top here first and foremost is that
mem stock investors or Apes as they call
themselves for reasons we'll get into
later aren't engaging with the reality
as you or I understand it you'll hear of
references to things that you're aware
of companies that exist in your univers
but you and apes aren't talking about
the same thing your version of GameStop
is an unprofitable Mall retailer that
was headed slowly but inexorably towards
bankruptcy due to societal shifts and
regular old mismanagement that in 2021
got something resembling a second chance
via once in a generation circumstances
that second chance might pan out into
some form of future relevance or at
least existence maybe but could just as
easily be squandered and result in
bankruptcy anyway one way or another the
price as it currently stands is still
floating well above GameStop's
historical Peak profitability during the
Heyday of the Wii PlayStation 3 and Xbox
360 so even a tremendous turnaround
would still almost certainly see the
stock price continue to decline the ape
version of GameStop is an apocalyptic
Catalyst The Chosen vessel through which
the world will be reborn a mythological
entity built Brick by Brick out of
communal desperation delusion and cope
obsessed with the financial concept of
Short Selling and a short squeeze their
version of reality is undoubtedly more
interesting more dramatic and more
Sensational but the reasons for its
existence are complex it is tempting to
say that the participants are merely
ignorant or incompetent but the sticky
truth is nuanced there are many elements
of ape lore that are Pure Performance
overt pieces of fiction that persist in
the collective narra simply because it
would be nice for Apes if they were true
the primary lens of ape culture born as
it was on Reddit is that of video games
they have cast a variety of people
businesses and institutions as their
matched opponent and will often post
taunting letters addressed to Ken
Griffin specifically or hedge funds
broadly where they invoke their prowess
in MMOs bro I play RuneScape I literally
grind for days to watch a number go up
one been playing 15 years and still not
lost interest they think it's going to
be any different now I just realized how
[__] shorts are they picked a fight
with the gaming industry the same people
who will grind hours on end losing
thousands of times in a row to Simply
get one win we refuse to end on a loss
we refuse to sell I did one of the most
degenerate grinds that exists for this
picture only this entire genre of post
is profoundly sad not merely because of
the implication that a willingness to
wander in circles for hours clicking on
Virtual plants is somehow a transferable
skill to playing the stock market but
because they all presume a very high
degree of symmetry and intentionality
they are based on the belief that like
in a video game both sides are knowingly
engaged in a match competition but when
you back up and evaluate the whole
picture there opponents aren't aware of
the game at all assuming that the ape is
even talking about a group that actually
exists on their forums they are winning
epic battles against automated trading
algorithms specifically tuned to drive
GameStop out of business they are in a
war with the hedgies who are always
every single day getting desperate and
running out of ammo in reality apes are
Shadow Boxing the random noise of the
market and losing it has become a layer
cake of every genre of magical thinking
New Faith religiosity reheated
conspiracy theories and general
Superstition with an added extra thick
frosting in the form of financial woo
get-rich quick culture sunk cost and
gamblers fallacy a lot of their language
is rooted in the culture of forchan and
Reddit they call themselves Apes partly
in reference to Planet of the Apes and
Starship Troopers but also because the
other words they call themselves made
them look bad when the media started to
pay attention it is a hazily defined
movement dispersed across all of social
social media and dozens of forums
burdened with 2 years of petty drama
infighting and fragmentation due to
their extreme beliefs their culture has
grown more and more insular over time so
their communication is predictably
littered with in jokes Niche references
shols abbreviations jargon and private
definitions of words borrowed from other
disciplines which can make it
understandably difficult to follow along
we can get there I believe in us we can
make this make sense
but boy howdy does the journey require a
journey the version of the story that
you're already familiar with is one
where a bunch of redditors tried to
short squeeze some hedge funds and get
rich in the process by buying GameStop
meanwhile the quote unquote mem stocks
turned over these companies pumped up by
amateur Traders on social platforms like
Reddit with the expressed purpose of
forcing certain hedge funds to lose
money well they plummeted today the
version of The Story You're not familiar
amiliar with is the one where 2 years
after the squeeze heat lamp Theory
penned by Reddit user 6 days one week
argues that financial service provider
computer shares operational algorithm is
being tricked by short hedge funds into
storing plan held shares in the dtcc
like burgers under a heat lamp and also
probably someone made it illegal to
report these heat lamp shares as
directly registered thus suppressing the
evidence that Apes own the float
although that post was low effort and
the speculation itself turned out not to
be completely correct my hunch was still
valid it was often attacked by what I
believe were bad actors asking me to
prove someone made it illegal the abuse
of computer shares algorithm was obvious
to Apes who were paying attention ever
since Ryan Cohen's I want to be the book
King tweet it was clear that Cohen was
signaling for Apes to terminate their
plans sell their fractionals and book
their shares what was not obvious was
the reaction of the mods who would
attempt to bury the story revealing
themselves to be paid shills clearly
compromised by the hedgies in order to
distract from heat lamp censorship of
heat lamp DD shows we are heading in the
right direction what the [__] is this
[__] so we still get push back for heat
lamp at other places but someone can
post a sponsor DD that is literally the
definition of fud and says in that
comments that DRS is pointless and M
will not happen the heat lamp Theory DD
to me is as impressive as the House of
Cards DD it's like the DDS from the
beginning of super ston so yeah there's
a lot of ground to cover before that
makes any sense at
[Music]
[Applause]
all the wheels of Finance spin beneath
the surface of the modern world
everywhere you look the impact can be
felt the modern Corporation consists of
many moving parts from manufacturing to
distribution to Communications likewise
the finances behind the corporation are
equally complex a delicately balanced
dance of equity and credit that
facilitates The Many Wonders of the
modern world one of the most
misunderstood and contentious mechanisms
of this dance is what is called a short
sale few subjects relating to exchange
practices have been characterized by
greater differences of opinion than that
of Short Selling
though many characterize shorting as a
toxic modern practice in reality it is
quite old and it has polarized people
for as long as it's existed but what is
a short sale a short sale involves
borrowing an asset selling it at current
market value and then returning it later
ideally at a lower price than when it
was sold but simply it's selling
borrowed Goods to buy back at a profit
two things happen with this Arrangement
first is that the short seller gets to
hold the full sale value for a period of
time until the asset is returned
providing them with capital that they
can use in the interum second is that
when the asset is returned this
represents not the moment where the
short seller makes money but merely when
they lock in their final profits the
risk reward proposition of Short Selling
is that gains are capped by the price at
the time of borrowing if an asset is
borrowed at $5 then the absolute maximum
profit is $5 discounting fees and
interest of course on the flip side the
risk profile the maximum losses of a
short sale are effectively infinite as
the price of the asset isn't bounded to
100% or even 10,000% of the original
sale price as the trend for the economy
as a whole is to grow a stock going from
$5 to $10 is far more common than stocks
going from $5 to zero in addition the
borrower is expected to pay the original
owner a recurring fee based on the value
of the asset similar to interest paid on
a loan called the cost of borrow or CTB
however unlike a personal loan that you
might already be familiar with such as a
mortgage where the payment Encompass
both interest and principle on a
schedule where the whole loan is
eventually paid off the cost to borrow
is paid every month PR rated by day with
no cap thus borrowing an asset for long
periods of time can quickly eat up
profit margins or even exceed the
original value of the asset itself for
these reasons it is uncommon to hold a
short position for long periods of time
even though the name Short Selling comes
from the bet that the asset will decline
or fall short it is coincidentally
appropriate that short plays tend toward
short time frames of weeks or months
rather than months or years however this
short time frame leaves the borrower
more exposed to short-term volatility
disruptions that might temporarily set a
company back without impacting the
overall health of the business can
benefit short sellers greatly while
unexpected good news can generate a
surge of excitement about a company that
may leave short sellers hurting and
lenders pressuring them to return the
asset or incur further liability at the
most extreme lenders can compel the
borrower to return the asset in full
regardless of the cost to the borrower
when short sellers are impelled to
return large volumes of shares all at
once this sudden buying pressure can
further potentiate upwards movement on
the price of the security applying
further margin pressures to other
existing short positions this situation
is commonly referred to as a short
squeeze as the short sellers are
squeezed out of their positions by the
accelerating
costs I mean they can try they can try
as hard as they want to try to
demoralize us but uh like as I always
say no sell no sell I'm not selling
power to the players power to the
shareholders power to the individual
investors each choosing for themselves
to a a a company that they believe in in
late January 2021 video game retailer
GameStop became a media sensation as the
value of their stock Rose from $20 to
just shy of $500 over the course of 4
days the exact Confluence of events that
led to this have been thoroughly
documented so we won't drag the point
out here but the critical takeaway is
this it was a once- in a-lifetime event
that hinged off multiple specific
coincidences one the pandemic made the
situation for Brick and Mortar retail
dire due to multivalent impacts so many
hedge funds had taken out short
positions against them anticipating a
continued decline in revenue and thus
share price two governments began to
distribute stimulus packages in an
attempt at offsetting the economic
impact of the pandemic three there was a
Zeitgeist to futility in the air that
financially the average person was
screwed the stimulus package wasn't
enough to fix anything so you might as
well blow it on something reckless in
specific hedge fund Melvin Capital holds
a truly Reckless short position in
GameStop that left the fund extremely
exposed if the price were to rise and
Traders on Reddit see this as an
opportunity and begin promoting it on
YouTube twitch and Twitter as the idea
of getting in on a potential GameStop
short squeeze spreads through social
media in late 2020 the messaging gets
flattened new people are flooding into
reddits Wall Street bets Forum they are
bringing with them their own ideas their
own politics their own expectations the
thing that really speaks to people and
thus works well for recruiting is the
idea that this is a chance to hurt Wall
Street as more more people Pile in the
experienced Traders get tired of
explaining things over and over thus new
people are being onboarded by people who
themselves have a stock trading career
best measured in hours these are users
who jumped onto forums and explicitly
asked how do I get in on GameStop as
fast as possible they're not getting a
lecture on risk management market
operations and exit strategy Not That
Wall Street bets would ever be a good
place to get them those they're getting
a hype speech about revenge for 2008 and
a barebone series of instructions on
what buttons to push potentiating that
any large leaderless movement with foggy
politics is going to attract a whole
slew of political opportunists from all
across the Spectrum who hope to steer
the tsunami in their preferred Direction
these people trying to transform it into
a coherent political movement inject and
amplify a lot of narrative about
solidarity and making a difference ape
together strong that's the kerosene that
primes this whole thing to turn into an
apocalyptic investment
cult this is a bold claim and it's
basically unfalsifiable but I feel like
I can point to the match the event that
really truly allowed for conspiratorial
thought to take permanent route in ape
culture and that's January 28th 2021 mid
morning when Robin Hood an app-based
free brokerage disabled the buying of
gme and a selection of other meme
stocks just this morning Robin Hood
which is really seen as the brokerage
firm of choice for a lot of those
younger investors said that in light of
recent volatility they're restricting
transactions for certain Securities to
position close only and to be clear that
means you can sell names like GameStop
but you can't buy them that was the day
the price hit its all-time high and in a
myth ology that was when they were on
the cusp of like total Revolution the
entire system was about to collapse and
apes were about to be crowned Victors
over Wall Street Robin Hood turning off
the buy button was from their point of
view an obvious sign of targeted
disruption the reality is far more
mundane Robin Hood runs a disruptive
brokerage with a very Tech bro it's
better to ask for forgiveness than
permission philosophy in a nutshell the
idea a is that they run all their
accounts by default as a kind of limited
margin account that they call instant
deposits you make an account start to
transfer money to your account the money
hasn't technically arrived yet but Robin
Hood lets you act like it has you want
to buy a stock Robin Hood pays for it
upfront and then just takes your money
when it finally arrives this undeniably
speeds things up and makes them
appealing to say a huge swath of people
who want to get on on this opportunity
to make wife changing money right now
before it's too late but exposes Robin
Hood to pretty substantial risk if a
million new users all sign up on the
same day and all immediately try and buy
GameStop at $300 a share via instant
deposits Robin Hood might risk running
out of money so the mundane reality is
that the influx of new users all making
pretty aggressive plays in a specific
basket of stocks stressed Robin Hood's
credit and threatened its collateral
across the board so they shut down
buying of those specific Securities to
protect themselves in the aftermath the
CEO of Robin Hood Vlad tenv denied that
the company had in fact basically run
out of money which may or may not have
being true but did confirm the
fundamentals of the threat so we're
really in unprecedented times and in
order to protect the firm and protect
our customers um we had to limit buying
in these in these stocks and to be
absolutely clear again wasn't go
ahead but it it sounds to me though that
you're suggesting that there was a
liquidity problem turns out giving
everyone a margin account is a good idea
until it isn't but that's boring you
know what's exciting they turned off the
buy button specifically to kill the
squeeze they want you to sell that's an
exciting idea the funny thing is that it
didn't even kill the pump sure Robin
Hood and a few other app-based Brokers
with a similar structure halted buying
but cash account Brokers were trading
just fine and gme still rallied pretty
hard the next day peing back over $400
the buy button was maybe a wakeup call a
sign that the music was probably about
to stop and you should cash out while
you can but what actually killed the
momentum was the
weekend When the Smoke Clears there's a
congressional hearing there's an SEC
report there's actually a ton of
scrutiny in and around the specific
events Melvin Capital eats some truly
staggering losses and needs to turn to
Citadel Securities for a bailout to
avoid closing entirely Regulators are
worried about how well they're
communicating with retail investors
legislators are worried social media
influencers aren't accountable enough
everyone knows that a charismatic figure
can fleece individuals and pump and dump
a single stock but do the events of
January suggest that influencers can
pose a systemic risk to
the market itself who if anyone was
responsible for January thing is that
while a bunch of people made a ton of
money off GameStop in January that money
has to come from somewhere in an actual
short squeeze the idea is that the money
comes from the short sellers they're the
ones buying vastly overpriced GameStop
shares so if this was a squeeze that's
simple but you know was it actually a
squeeze the SEC report didn't come out
until fall 2021 and while still pretty
dry and Technical it does try to engage
with the general public who know a bit
about the stock market but aren't Deep
In The Weeds it's not Flawless but the
conclusions are sound GameStop was a
complicated mix of activities that fed
off one another there was a short
Squeeze In the Mix a bunch of the
traffic that saw GameStop starting to
pump at the beginning of the week was
driven by known short sellers closing
their position
but the main body of it all the buyers
who push the price up to just shy of
$500 that was overwhelmingly retail
buyers the people left holding the bag
when the music stopped wasn't Melvin
Capital wasn't Citadel wasn't black rock
it was apes and a lot of those Apes were
new recruits whose first day of stock
trading in their lives was from
installing Robin Hood and buying gme
that week the the story of Apes post
squeeze is a bunch of people standing
around A trashed hotel room at 5:00 a.m.
asking when the party is supposed to
start a bunch of newly minted bag
holders trying to manifest another even
larger squeeze because the only way they
could possibly make money off of their
$420 gme shares is if it somehow goes
even higher everything becomes fodder
for theories about what really happened
and why the price didn't just keep going
up direct share registration naked
shorts R show none of this mattered to
Apes at all in January but suddenly in
February and March these ideas get
injected as explanations for why the
squeeze didn't keep squeezing they will
in the months that follow recast January
as the sneeze both to suggest that Not
only was it not the main event it was a
tiny blip compared to the inevitable
true squeeze the mother of all short
squeezes
moas i' like to welcome you all to the
bagio resort and casino in Scenic Las
Vegas Nevada uh we're just uh you know
enjoying uh enjoying some early
tendies there's there's some news on the
wind that uh that that big things are
coming big things are coming as early as
this weekend and uh and bobb's pumping I
don't think anything could really go
wrong I think uh I think there's a lot
of people out there who want to make it
look like things are going wrong I hold
for the infinity pool just I buy I hold
a
DRS moas is a tricky thing to talk about
first of all it is a pure Financial
conspiracy theory we're used to
conspiracy theories that intersect with
Finance most get around to the subject
of international Bankers eventually but
those theories tend to start in
sociology science or politics and then
expand to cover Finance as they grow
moas starts in finance with the
operations of the stock market so just
from the word go the subject is already
inundated with unfamiliar terminology
organizations and acronyms this is all
compounded by the fact that the exact
composition of the belief is Mercurial
moas is a vessel conspiracy containing
many other modular theories these
theories are disperate obtuse
self-referential and often contradictory
if not outright paradoxical it is as a
whole a theory that resists critical
thought at every turn if you try to
formulate an all-encompassing version of
it you will find only frustration the
jar moas itself is the belief that for
some reason or another GameStop or some
other mem stock company is going to
Skyrocket in value and make everyone who
times it right unfathomably rich in the
blink of an eye everything inside the
jar is the how and the why taken as a
whole moas is many things it's an
apocalyptic event it's an infinite money
glitch it's revenge against Wall Street
it's salvation for those who gambled
away their life savings but above all
moas is a story and that story goes a
little something like this what you need
to know before the moas during the moas
and after the mo ass all in one video
well let's start by chugging this [__]
and get going we know we own the float
so if they have to cover that means they
have to pay the price that we say now if
we hold to 10 million that's what they
have to pay so if it goes to 100,000 if
it goes to 250,000 if it goes to 1,000
if it goes to 500 that ain't the squeeze
baby that ain't the squeeze what's the
squeeze is once it's past 10 million
then we're squeezing at some point in
the near future in my opinion we have
the most moaz actually happening where
we've survived all the F we survived the
short attacks and then the moaz happens
baby and then we pass our floor of 10
million or 20 million and we get up to a
ceiling of let's say $420 million a
share and if you're raising your
eyebrows that's not possible the whole
economy will be ruin shut up you don't
know what you're talking about do your
research 500 million per share is not a
meme I am dead serious major Financial
firms most notably hedge funds such as
Ken Griff and Citadel owe their profits
to massive volumes of fraudulent naked
short sales flooding the market with
Phantom shares that suppress the price
of companies like GameStop AMC Theaters
and Bed Bath and Beyond this scheme has
generated unfathomable amounts of debt
that hedgies could never afford to pay
back hundreds of billions of shares owed
that don't actually exist and thus
cannot be returned adding up to
trillions of dollars of debt so their
only hope is if the victim company goes
out of business entirely allowing the
hedgies to walk away with tax-free gains
the risk is so extreme that it justifies
every employee at hundreds of financial
institutions the media the government
and the courts all cooperating to keep
the conspiracy Under Wraps but if that
scheme were to be revealed if Citadel
were forced to buy back those hundreds
of billions of shares it would trigger a
short squeeze that would send GameStop's
Share value into phone number prices and
create a Cascade that could topple the
entire global economy because there are
so many fake shares Apes have already
bought more shares than are supposed to
exist they own the float and have thus
positioned themselves to be the
beneficiaries of that apocalyptic
unraveling as long as they can remain
United and refuse to sell their shares
if no one sells then the supply is zero
and the price is infinite then Apes can
dictate not only the price but they can
make demands if Ken Griffin isn't sent
to prison for his purported crimes the
deal is off no sell no sell as the
evidence of the fraud ripples through
the economy as the entire stock market
is revealed to be a sham faith in
institutions will falter and in an
existential crisis the government will
be forced to make Apes whole or else
face their own Extinction precipitating
the greatest transfer of wealth in human
history and then when the Flames of moas
have cleansed the Earth it will usher in
a golden age of humanity stewarded by
the true Diamond handed Apes who did not
flinch in the face of poultry th% gains
did not become paperhand [__] over
mere wife changing money but hled hled
in the face of fear hled in the face of
uncertainty hled in the face of Doubt so
what happens in theory when they can't
get enough shares even with the price in
the millions the price goes to the tens
of millions then hundreds of millions
billions if it has to price is just
supply and demand all I have to do is
buy one
stock buy one stock GameStop feel good
about it and watch the world crumble a
thing that's kind of beautiful about a
short squeeze is that you don't really
need to do anything you just need to be
in the right place at the right time and
a thing that marbles through the whole
subject of meme stocks is a Sublime
laziness this is a characteristic of all
get-rich quick schemes but it's
important to keep in mind as Apes build
this complex Theory as they fill the jar
and as they become increasingly irate
when moas fails to materialize that all
they've done all they've actually done
is press a buy Button as morance said
all he has to do is buy one stock feel
good about it and watch the world
crumble it's just reddit's version of
The Rapture now in these sample
narratives of moas we've already made a
mistake which is trying to pin down the
specific in some coherent way a critical
element of talking about moas is that
the component beliefs are modular the
jar the part where apes get rich is the
only constant any specific belief can be
readily discarded or swapped without
posing a risk to the Integrity of the
structure as a whole for example many
moas theories cite the idea that Citadel
wouldn't need to pay taxes on any gains
from short positions if the victim
company goes completely out of business
this makes narrative sense but just
isn't true like there there's not much
else that needs to be done to debunk
that it's just false but removing it
from the jar doesn't really do anything
and it also doesn't matter if you debunk
it because Apes will just put it back in
anyway as a result the mem stock belief
system has become an absolute Rat's Nest
of false threads misinformation willful
ignorance and reheated conspiracy
theories from the 9s all of which has
been constantly adjusted to compensate
for the fact that reality keeps
disproving it it's a mess so how does a
philosophy like moas develop that is
actually a shockingly long explanation a
major problem here as I said is that a
lot of this is contradictory and
circular a pile of half-baked theories
cooked up peace meal by Apes with no
understanding of the underlying subject
working specifically to find a thing
that would would need to be true in
order to maintain the conspiracy Cascade
the only reason they believe there are
hundreds of billions of fake GameStop
shares in circulation is because that's
the thing that needs to be true in order
to explain why they believe shorts never
closed in 2021 and they believe shorts
never closed in 2021 because it's the
thing that needs to be true in order for
the squeeze to still be on the table and
the squeeze needs to still be on the
table because otherwise what are you
doing why are you here but also a lot of
these specific ideas they got them from
somewhere and investigating that
somewhere just opens up a rabbit hole
where you spend months delving into
other pre-existing conspiracy theories
that have tried to graft themselves onto
the mem stock movement February 2021
following the price of GameStop crashing
back to Earth many Apes who bought in
late or held through it were extremely
salty and needed something or someone to
blame that wasn't just you know making a
poor financial decision based on Reddit
hype posts the Fiasco with Robin Hood
turning off the buy button initially
floated to the top because there are
even in our reality some questions about
how that was handled and Robin Hood's
business model that are very much worth
asking Apes of course care about none of
that all the talk about Market reform is
just smoke they're here to crash the
system and get rich so what they see in
the Robin Hood Fiasco is targeted
disruption someone pulled strings to
turn off the buy button and Stop The
Squeeze which means someone's scared the
whole thing must still be primed to pop
off again Apes declare that shorts never
closed the squeeze never ended it's just
in a bit of a gully and it's going to
shoot back up any day now if they can
get the pressure back up the second
thing they latch on to is that Citadel
bailed out Melvin now in reality this
wasn't a philanthropic gesture it was a
lot closer to a protection racket
Shakedown because Wall Street are all
greedy [__] and Melvin folded under
the the pressure in 2022 anyway but it
gives Apes a villain Ken Griffin Apes
assert that he must have personally
called Vlad tenev at Robin Hood and told
him to turn off the buy button in order
to protect Citadel and then lied to
Congress when he told them under oath
that he didn't do that this seed
narrative proves just sticky enough to
keep people emotionally invested and
from there Apes crowdsourced the
explanations tacking on more and more
oblique ideas lifted out of the
complexity and obfuscation of capital
markets in order to explain why this
thing is still primed to pop part of
what makes moas persuasive why people
buy in is that very complexity and
obfuscation people come into the subject
with well-founded skepticism of Wall
Street The Narrative That Wall Street is
corrupt Reckless and greedy is
persuasive in no small part because it
isn't wrong so memet prelit present
themselves as the ones who are cutting
through the darkness exposing the
deliberately obfuscated truth of how the
market really works democratizing the
Ivory Tower of Finance now despite its
reputation Finance as a subject is in
fact something that you a lay person can
learn it is a lot less impenetrable than
it seems Wall Street is a wash with B
minus students who wrapped their heads
around it you can too but we need to be
careful here because just because the
subject is more accessible than you
might think that doesn't mean it's void
of actual honest to God complexity and
Nuance understanding how to evaluate a
mutual fund or trying your hand at
making money day trading is not that
complex understanding loopholes in
Securities
regulation is so in the theory of moas
we have a collision of the rhetoric of
the democratization of Finance with the
actual impenetrable stuff that even the
majority of the people on Wall Street
don't bother to understand and the
systems of the economy are so
intertwined and obtuse that it's
possible to sculpt almost any Story one
can imagine through the framing it is a
perfect recipe for someone to very
confidently present you with extremely
wrong information that you have no
reference point to evaluate from and if
it wasn't already clear moas is almost
totally devoid of any actual economics
like think about it their theory is that
Wall Street is so reckless and greedy
that they have created this powder keg
that will allow Apes to make
unfathomable amounts of money off of
moas but despite this Powder Keg sitting
in the open where redditors could
stumble into it no one on Wall Street is
greedy or Reckless enough to pursue it
despite having substantially greater
resources at their disposal to do so and
the conspiracy Apes claim to be
unraveling is both incredibly vast and
yet leaves no material evidence no memos
no emails no insiders just ghosts in the
trading data but also Apes will will
readily discard the data if it tells the
wrong story they'll just claim the price
is fake the stock is manipulated bad
news is deliberate misinformation you
can only trust the numbers when the line
goes up since you can't trust news data
or even company filings the only thing
to do is buy at any price and hold for
moas the mother of all short squeezes is
a lot of things but it's not a trading
strategy but please if you think this is
at all unfair to the ape thesis feel
free to do your own research peruse the
super ston flip book page with over 200
Reddit posts dressed up to look like
books enjoy such critically acclaimed
works as the Billionaire Boys Club by
badass Trader trust death and divorce
the parts of Ken Griffin's life that
haven't been published and infinity War
the Final Exit DD compilation by gerinet
regardless of the lack of actual Finance
underpinning it we do need to establish
some basic literacy in order to explain
why it all falls apart and to
contextualize what's so fascinating
about the community that has grown up
around it so real quick what is a stock
anyway stocks or shares aren't a real
thing they're an intangible legal claim
to some portion of a company or Venture
they exist entirely in the realm of the
social contract and in some form or
another are as old as civilization
somewhere in ancient history a couple
people got together and we like hey
let's pull our resources dig a mine and
then split the proceeds and in that
moment the share was born then the
second dude was like Hey I don't really
want to run a mine anymore I'm trading
my share of the mine for a goat farm and
now you have invented an equity Market
today's Equity markets are a vastly more
complex version of that and the whole
thing is in a constant state of flux but
the core concept is still there a stock
is an intangible bundle of legal rights
that you can sell but you're probably
thinking to yourself what about stock
certificates hundreds of years ago if
you wanted to sell your shares in a mine
you'd need to go to the company offices
where they keep The Ledger of all the
people that own a share in the mine tell
them I'm selling my share to this guy
here take me off the list and put his
name instead upsides the company knows
exactly who owns what portion of the
company downsides huge pain in the ass
to address the fact that this was a pain
in the ass some companies decided to
embody the intangible rights into a
tangible object a certificate a piece P
of paper imbued with legal magic that
says possession of the paper is
identical to possession of the legal
rights so that people who wanted to sell
their share or even just a portion of
their share could do so by handing over
the certificates but that's not a
perfect system you've probably already
thought of some flaws and once the
telephone was invented it became its own
pain in the ass what do you mean I need
to actually move a box full of magic
paper from Brooklyn to Manhattan what a
waste of time time glossing over 100
Years of Securities regulations
following the invention of the telephone
and then the computer the model that we
currently use is what's called
Securities entitlements and beneficial
ownership when you buy shares via Robin
Hood your Shares are kept in a central
depository the depository trust and
Clearing Corporation or dtcc with Robin
Hood's name on them and then Robin Hood
keeps their own list of which of their
clients owns what forming a chain of
beneficial ownership now the dtcc the
New York Stock Exchange NASDAQ these are
not government entities they're private
corporations that are overseen by the
Securities and Exchange Commission the
SEC which is part of the government they
are designed as self-regulating
organizations that's a phrase that
throws up some red flags but it is a
term with a specific meaning designating
an organization as self-regulating gives
them some slack to do their neoliberal
profit mode of routine subject to the
approval and oversight of the regulator
if they want a new toy they can have it
but we aren't paying for it none of this
means that self-regulating orgs or the
SEC get automatic or unwavering Faith
but it means you can't just claim
self-regulated is anonymous with
unregulated to explain why this vast
conspiracy has invisibly rampaged
completely unchecked the actual stock
market and its mechanics suck in the
worst possible way
the usual way they carry literal
centuries of bad habits cut corners and
self-interest we didn't end up with high
Security Bank vaults full of jumbo sized
Magic Paper because it was the best
system the central depository model of
clearing and settlement has a lot of
genuine flaws the kind of stuff that
fuels beef between experts in the
Uniform Commercial
Code perhaps Professor kogan's criticism
of the amendments may really be due to
the fact that they transfer the
provisions on creation and Perfection of
security interest in uncertificated
Securities from article 9 to article 8
practitioners under article 9 have been
known to Harbor a jealous regard for
that area of practice which has
traditionally been their
own Savage all this is to say that
criticisms of this system are very easy
to find but it's also very easy to
misunderstand what you're looking at the
primary lens that Apes view this complex
Market through is of course the short
sale because it is the one thing they
know about the stock market it is the
only thing that matters it is made
compelling by the fact that short
selling is controversial well outside
ape circles and has been for a very long
time it's been called blatant thuggery
by us Congressman Dennis hasard the
Malaysian finance ministry wanted to
cane short sellers but light similar to
the punishment carried out on juveniles
during World War I the New York Stock
Exchange imposed Short Selling
regulations in part out of fear that
German spies would utilize short sales
to harm the economy but for Apes who
were introduced to the concept by The
Big Short it's a personal
insult short everything that guy has
touched I want half a billion more swaps
and all the while short sales have the
unique Quirk of putting downward
pressure on the stock price by
increasing Supply so short sales do
contain a self-fulfilling component now
there's a Nobel prize in economics
waiting for you if you can quantify that
self-fulfilling element but for Apes the
theory alone is enough to overwhelm all
other considerations for them it goes to
the furthest possible extreme short
sales can kill a profitable company
stoned dead when taken in combination
Short Selling becomes a literal
conspiracy the act itself becomes
Financial terrorism quite
literally whatever retail buys they
short if an institution's holding it
it's not going to get shorted why do you
think Amazon became the most overpowered
Merchant there is I work for the company
and I can tell you it's because retail
wasn't holding it so then their ticker
can go up because institutions were
holding it one of the truly
revolutionary moments in the development
of moases a theory came when Apes
dredged up a conspiracy theory favored
by dotcom companies who were convinced
that they were being targeted for
Destruction by naked short sellers naked
short sales are kind of tricky to talk
about because the well of discussion is
so poisoned by these conspiracy
theorists a naked short sale is when you
generate a short sale without actually
borrowing a share first it is a real
thing it is illegal and has been for a
while people have gone to jail for doing
it it was a historical problem but not
for the reasons apes and their ilk claim
the problem is compounded by the fact
that a number of legitimate Market
mechanics resemble naked Short Selling
if you squint so there's the real thing
off over in the corner that people go to
jail for doing because like there's
evidence of their crimes and then
there's a fantasy version espoused by
cranks where shadowy figures destroy
companies for profit without leaving any
evidence the infuriating thing is that
it really kind of doesn't even matter
because most Apes don't bother to
distinguish between regular short sales
and naked short sales Apes start from
short sellers are the bad guys and rail
against anything that enables Short
Selling like stock lending which is
obviously important to Short Selling
because you can't borrow a share unless
someone's lending them Apes only rope in
a crank version of naked shorts when
they eventually need to explain why
there's no evidence of the short
position that would need to exist in
order for the short squeeze to still be
on the table so let's walk through it in
mid-march of 2021 a Reddit post on Wall
Street bets received 22,000 up votes
arguing that the squeeze hadn't truly
ended anybody with a brain knows that
gme is not fundamentally worth its
current price of this post at $215 per
share the main talking point across all
the investing subreddits and news
outlets was the fact that GMA short
percentage reached a height of 140% but
what does 140% float mean did the hedge
fund short SL borrow more shares than
even
existed well yes that's called naked
shorting but it's more complicated than
that by the standards of present day
theories this is rather quaint the
redditor mistakenly believed that the
short sellers had survived the squeeze
by purchasing shares created by market
makers whose job is to trade to
customers regardless of whether they own
the asset at the time mandating
something resembling naked short selling
at times to the author the excess of
short interest was clear evidence of a
naked short position of at least 40% of
the entire share count that isn't sound
in fact it misunderstands BAS basic
mechanics of how a short sale even works
in this instance we've exceeded 100%
short interest because buyers are blind
to the intent of the seller no new
shares have been created a single share
can be bought lent and sold as many
times in a row as there are parties
willing to engage in the trade mere Days
Later an article would be discovered
from the blog oilprice.com your number
one source for your oil and energy news
the article reframed the GameStop
incident not as a short squeeze nor as a
retail friend but as a skirmish between
retail investors and manipulative
illegal naked Short Selling GameStop was
the victim of a malicious short attack
the exact same thing that is happening
to the Canadian mining sector this
article would validate the Apes
anxieties the buy button wasn't some
isolated incident predicated on boring
details about credit and margin this was
systemic Wall Street has been doing
stuff like this to companies since the
bubble The Squeeze needed to be killed
because Apes were on to something as a
conspiracy theory these narratives of
naked short attacks endure because
they're convenient impossible to
disprove but there's also just enough
truth to it that it can't be debunked
like your typical conspiracy theory to
this end Apes become very concerned
about ideas of fake ownership and fake
shares two separate ideas with their own
implications you need to have real
ownership sh of real shares as
demonstrated earlier the subject of what
owning a stock even is is kind of a
weird mess built on centuries of Jank
which makes it really easy for Apes to
Simply describe it as fake ownership
beneficial ownership via a broker is
just an IOU and they're probably lending
your shares out to short sellers which
means financial terrorism the term fake
share refers to numerous different ideas
and they can be used interchangeably the
specifics are irrelevant it could be the
dilutive effects of naked shorts
mislabeled orders rehypothecation the
obligation Warehouse the ghost of the
stock borrow program or persistent
failures to deliver doesn't matter
they've churned through a dozen
different theories for where fake shares
might be coming from and might be hiding
for Apes trading is like a video game
and they're all collectively hammering
away to find an exploit to steal Ken
Griffin's fat loot the actual end boss
that apes are at war with is reality
GameStop at this point in March is still
massively overvalued and the
participants in the January 2021 frenzy
are either cashing out some sweet gains
or cutting their losses the Apes who are
in really deep are convinced that it's
going to shoot back up any day now but
it doesn't it's volatile it swings a lot
on any given day but the ultimate trend
is down and the explanation they come up
with is that clearly this is because of
short attacks normally short attacks are
specific identifi able transactions made
with the intent of spooking investors
and triggering a wider sell-off to Apes
they are persistent invisible and need
to be occurring in such high quantities
as to defy all reason therefore they
must be occurring via naked shorts and
the attackers are avoiding closing the
position somehow so logically if the
only reason the price is going down is
because of these short attacks then that
must mean that GameStop is acre more and
more short interest with each one the
actual short interest in GameStop peaked
at 140% which is an astoundingly
Reckless situation and is the reason
Melvin ate dirt but once the Apes ran
the numbers themselves they valued the
true short interest at over
99,9% and that number is pretty old at
this point within a year history would
be Rewritten and it would be claimed
that the Catalyst for the gme squeeze
wasn't fomo or memes it was the
discovery of fake
shares so the idea is that there are a
handful of real shares lost in the
slurry of fake shares Apes need to get
their hands on these real shares and how
they go about this is very funny as an
example there is a theory that stock
options require the broker to deliver a
real share so some Apes try to exercise
outof the- money options they want to
buy shares for more than their current
market value deliberately losing money
that kind of behavior is indicative of
an investor who has either made a
mistake is trying to manipulate the
stock price or is just incredibly stupid
possibly all three so intermediaries
won't let you do it when their request
is refused Apes go nuclear at the
customer support reps making Sovereign
citizen esque arguments as to why it's
criminal for them to infringe on the
Investor's god-given right to lose money
on purpose but Above All Else true
ownership demands the use of the direct
registration system DRS allows the
investor ownership of a security to be
recorded in their own name on the books
of the issuing company's transfer agent
it exists to make this circuitous mess
more palatable by giving investors an
alternative and it has a few legitimate
functions there's nothing wrong with DRS
as a concept but Apes again distort it
to the point of being barely
recognizable Apes gravitate towards it
initially as a catalyst for moas a way
that they can force the hypothetical
9000% short interest to close and as a
belief that there's so many fake shares
in circulation that direct registration
is the only way they'll be able to prove
they have real shares during moas but it
very quickly evolves into a loyalty
ritual and you know it's always tomorrow
until it's today so I guess I'm just H
till I get paid and I
RS
[Music]
rsrr the central depository model was
built built to specifically enable
transactions to occur quickly it was
built to be brutally efficient Above All
Else DRS by Design reintroduces
inefficiency in transferring ownership
it makes selling your shares more
expensive and it's slow many transfer
agents require you to send important
requests by mail like with an envelope
that makes it a kind of symbolic
castration you're proving your
conviction to the cause by hindering
your ability to sell it's Community
policy to keep your entire stake in DRS
if you keep some portion of it with your
broker it means you're enabling them to
lend your shares to short Sellers and
commit Financial terrorism and the only
reason you would keep the shares with
your broker is if you were planning to
sell you aren't thinking of selling
right having opted into DRS the
shareholder receives mail from the
transfer agent as evidence of their
ownership these letters are regularly
paraded on the subreddits posed
alongside other sacred objects objects
demonstrating loyalty to the company God
a lot of these have firearms somewhere
within this process the ape ascends to
the status of a Bonafide shareholder
they hold real shares entirely locked
out of the reach of Wall Street so I
want you to visualize this you're hooked
on watching the price of GameStop every
day whenever the price goes down which
it does often it's because Ken Griffin
who orchestrated to kill the squeeze is
illegally naked shorting gme in order to
suppress the price so every week gme
continues to accumulate more and more
short interest that means that every day
the theoretical payout of moas gets
larger and larger in fact the
plausibility of Citadel ever willingly
closing ever slowly winding down their
position grows more and more impossible
moas becomes inevitable once the
conspiracy is unveiled something like
99% of GameStop shares will be revealed
to be fake at the same time it's
revealed that Citadel needs to buy back
90 times GameStops value worth of gme
the short sellers now need to buy back
real shares which are exclusively held
by Apes this alone would be absurd but
it gets worse under the infinity pool
Theory Apes will simply refuse to sell
their shares the supply will literally
be zero so the ticker might as well read
Infinity it's just supply and demand the
plan is to never let the short sellers
cover their position and hold them
hostile in a basement and drip feed them
one share at a time with each ape making
wife changing money with each sale the
purported values are childish and
totally arbitrary ranging from10 to $500
million per share as we've seen the
limiter on this is naturally you know
reality Citadel can't pay Infinity
dollars per share nor can they pay 10
million a share but don't worry Apes
have already mapped out how the dominoes
will fall what Unthinkable happens in
more than 60% desire to hold gme to at
least seven figures DTC can only cover
67 trillion what happens then then it
goes to then it goes to the FED
Raj the FED has to turn on the printer
so Citadel will be vaporized the instant
the news breaks and their obligations
will flow to the central depository
itself a central depository has never
defaulted before we don't know for
certain what will happen but Apes have
done their research and all agree that
in the event the dtcc goes bust the
first priority for compensation will be
Bonafide shareholders to the detriment
of all others like that 67 trillion
figure suggests that the dtcc will
liquidate your dad's Investment
Portfolio to buy shares in GameStop once
the depository defaults we get something
resembling Global Financial collapse but
the US government still has an
obligation to compensate the redditors
for their losses in the pure version of
moas Apes take up the the mantle of God
Kings of a whole new economy their new
market would be blockchainbased trading
stock as nfts forcing short sellers to
track down and return specific
identifiable shares because Apes have a
collective fantasy about being
personally contacted by short sellers
begging them to sell moas realists argue
instead that the US government faced
with this existential crisis will simply
cut a deal with the apes and whether
Apes ought to squeeze the White House is
a point of contention within the
movement so to sum up moas is an
infinite money glitch built on the idea
that Wall Street as a whole conspires to
smother dying companies through naked
short sales they do this through
exploiting flaws and securities
ownership and stock lending to produce
fake shares GameStop avoided its
execution because redditors intervened
via a coincidence of Destiny and that
positions GameStop as a catalyst to
unravel the greatest fraud in history
with a side effect being that the US
government will hand the keys to Fort
Knox to a bunch of redditors as a down
payment for their shares in video game
retailer GameStop so that's the play all
the Apes need to do now is find evidence
of some fake shares how hard can that be
yeah I'm picking up more GameStop I'm
picking up more Bed Bath and Beyond I'm
I'm super excited for Bed Bath and
Beyond I'm seeing a lot of bullish
sentiment online a lot of really good
peer reviewed theories some DD you know
Cohen's still in this play ion's in this
play we're going to see some
collaboration between those two ion
through newal Brands buys up Bed Bath
and Beyond spins off bye-bye baby to
Cohen he merges that with Teddy and that
forms the foundation of jica which
lights the fuse on the rocket for
GameStop so how do you prove that fake
shares exist the company will tell you
how many shares they have issued they
will call it the total outstanding share
count for example here's GameStop's 10q
from June 2021 reporting
71,1
15,1 31 outstanding shares but that is
the number that is supposed to exist if
you think fake Shares are being
introduced into the system that number
is only useful to check your work you
have to do a share count true rigorous
investigations of share counts occur so
rarely that there isn't really a good
comparison to draw from at minimum it's
a hugely disruptive process that
involves cooperation from basically
every branch of the stock market Market
it's something GameStop lacks the
authority to do themselves and the mere
mention of it might Foster bearish
sentiment you know suggesting to
investors that their shares may be
compromised with no basis for that
belief so it shouldn't be surprising
that to the best of our knowledge
GameStop hasn't acknowledged any part of
the moas
conspiracy directly wink wink nudge
nudge this means the apes are on their
own to expose the conspiracy from the
outside the method Apes first latch on
to is via shareholder votes we've
already seen the issues that can arise
from Counting shares directly from the
market totally normal business
transactions can resemble illusionary
shares and it's not possible to work
backwards to solve for the initial share
count especially when the number you're
after contains an unknown amount of fake
shares when a shareholder loans their
share for a short sale they are owed a
share they still consider themselves a
shareholder but they lose access to
their voting rights otherwise you'd have
one share providing two separate votes
if not more that gives you a hint of
where this is headed one share
translates to one vote so if every
shareholder is involved in a vote the
vote count should total precisely 100%
of the outstanding share count if the
number exceeds 100% that has to be the
product of naked shorts Phantom shares
or dodgy voting over voting is a real
thing in corporate governance and it's a
whole complex topic that neither of us
want to endure thankfully the ape theory
is extremely simple they aren't trying
to reveal a moderate discrepancy in the
share count they believe there are
dozens of times more shares in
circulation than intended and that Apes
have already bought far far far more
than the 72 million real shares as the
phrase goes Apes already own the float
we know we own the float let's set the
scene here a little it's April May 2021
mo ass as a theory is still evolving
rapidly and GameStop has a corporate
vote coming up on June 9th Apes spend
weeks whipping up support for the vote
promoting it all over Reddit explaining
how to submit your vote to your broker
and proclaiming it as an opportunity to
really truly finally Stick It To Wall
Street expose the criminal naked short
attacks on GameStop and Trigger another
squeeze this was such a big deal that
numerous Apes traveled to Texas to
attend the shareholder meeting in person
and thousands of Apes tuned into the
influencer live streams that treated
this Bale procedural vote with the gravy
toss of a major political election
waiting in suspense for the results
present more than majority of all shared
confirmed more than
majority um so okay so so there are
there are more shares there are more
votes they confirmed there are more
shares that's 100% no they confirm there
are more votes than shares that's what
I'm saying that's more than
100% yeah if that's a direct quote if
you have that and that's Source that's
it because if we're saying more than
majority majority is just 50% no no no
it wasn't majority they said more votes
than outstanding shares oh [__] that's
huge I'm waiting for that 8K to come out
and say we had 100 percent hundreds of
percent more than what we expected I'm
literally expecting hundreds of percent
more but that in that aspect more than a
majority if it outstands a flat it's
still more than a majority that's
legally but it was more than more than
majority last year
too yeah so it didn't work GameStop
didn't announce that nine times as many
votes were cast as should have even been
possible they just kind of nodded at the
fact that voter turnout was high this is
actually how DRS entered this story in
the first place Dr Suzanne trimbath or
queen Kong as the Apes nicknamed her has
been promoting DRS to retail investors
for 20 some odd years and the utility
here is the same as the vote since the
number of shares that Apes presume exist
is some cartoonish multiple of the
actual number it should be trivial to
demonstrate and unlike the vote this
would cut Brokers out of the picture
entirely thus began an even more intense
campaign to DRS gme and get GameStop to
begin reporting the number of direct
registered shares this
this was a lock Apes own the float after
all the crime is so vast that even
mediocre participation will expose some
truly unreasonable numbers 80 million 90
million 300 million direct registered
shares in a company that only has 72
million shares to begin with and then
then comes the
Reckoning yeah that one didn't pan out
either
okay so the headband maybe I should
explain this it's a it's an
homage uh like really everything I do is
an homage to my hero uh dfv or deep
[__]
value and at this point we need to talk
about a man named Keith Gil an
instrumental figure in all of this who
those familiar with the story probably
feel has been conspicuously absent up to
this
point this is Keith Gil AKA dfv AKA
roaring Kitty he is simultaneously
extremely important to the ape movement
and utterly inconsequential to our story
and for that reason it is worth
profiling him in order to illustrate
that contradiction to some he basically
invented mem stocks while to others he
is merely the mouthpiece through which
moas made itself known to the world the
reality in contrast is almost
unrecognizable in our reality he is a
registered Securities broker who was
working by day at the insurance broker
Mass Mutual in his spare time he streams
investment tutorials on YouTube under
the Alias roaring Kitty and posts on
Reddit under the handle deep [__]
value next slide it is 2019 and Keith's
hope is to become something of an
investment influencer based on his
roaring Kitty investment philosophy
which as the name suggests is a small
but aggressive strategy next slide as
the working subject for this Keith has a
theory inspired by a blog post written
by Dr Dr Michael bur that GameStop is
undervalued the idea is pretty
straightforward and honestly rather
modest GameStop has been trending
downward for several years but has
historically always seen a significant
bump in value at the start of a new
console generation and the ninth gen
consoles are on the horizon next slide
while consumer habits are shifting away
from malls in general and aggressively
to digital distribution for games in
specific and while GameStop's
relationship with manufacturers and
develop is no longer what it once was
Gil's opinion is the market is overly
pessimistic about how much life is left
in physical media longterm his view is
that GameStop still has multiple
opportunities to Pivot the business to
something more forward-looking
especially if they can expect a
significant spike in Revenue in the near
future this is an argument that GameStop
is trading at $4 to $8 he feels it
should be trading at $8 to $10 and has
the capability of going reasonably
higher as the ninth gen consoles carry
the 2020 holiday season that's what I
think I think about GameStop I think it
is it is at least a double I think it is
probably a triple but it legit could be
a four to five bagger it could be
looking out I don't know looking out 6
to 18 months or so um yeah so that's
what I think if you disagree with that
that's fine I like I I've been wrong
about plenty of things in the past next
slide of course he couldn't have seen
the Corona virus pandemic coming and how
that would both decimate brick and
mortar retail with malls getting hit
particularly hard and stress supply
lines for both the retailers and their
vendors next slide gild chips away at
this thesis for over a year streaming
about it regularly posting stream
highlights as Standalone videos and
defending and refining the thesis in
discussions with other Traders on Reddit
even as the situation looks ever more
dire for GameStop as the ninth gen
console launch is set to be hammered by
problems all the way up and down the
chain from raw materials to shipping
stoppages next slide however as the meme
stock craze takes route and in
particular identifies GameStops
unusually high short interest as a
possible squeeze play Keith is already
pretty deep in on GameStop and willing
to ride it out for which he is rewarded
pretty handsomely here is Keith on
Christmas Day 2020 discussing GameStop
breaking his original optimistic price
target of $20 hey what's up everybody
cheers happy Friday happy holidays I
hope everyone's having a great week
surprise GameStops up about 5x from when
I uploaded those videos over the summer
so that's great to see when you have a
thesis and in buy and large it unfolds
as you hope that it could um that's nice
so it shouldn't be taken for granted it
doesn't always happen so um that's great
and um yeah it's uh just to clear up
some potential misconceptions this this
was a true YOLO for me
when when I was building this position
uh last year we had nowhere close to a
million dollars um I certainly do not
drive a Lambo we rent this house that
you that you see so it's been a wild
ride for us as a family and um and I I'm
it has been just so much fun to
experience that with you over the past
couple of months I hope you had uh some
some fun as well and maybe if you if you
even picked up on some educational
elements along the way all the better
but it has brought me tremendous joy to
to to just share in this what has turned
out to be a bit of a case study right as
some of us feel and it has brought me
tremendous joy and um and if you have
have had a good time as well that makes
me feel great next slide when all was
said and done at the end of January
Keith quit his job and took home an
estimated $25 million for which Maxine
Waters hauled his ass in front of
Congress to answer some questions about
what the hell happened and if you know
he maybe did a bit of a pump and dump
next slide Keith accurately in my
opinion insisted that while he was a
higher profile member of the wave he was
ultimately just another member of a
decentralized movement and demonstrably
had been personally advocating GameStop
as a potential profitable move for well
over a year I also want to say that I
support retail investors right to invest
in what they want when they want I
support the right of individuals to send
a message based on how they invest as
for me I like the stock I'm as bullish
as I've ever been on a potential
turnaround for GameStop and I remain
invested in the company thank you cheers
everyone next slide Apes read literally
all of this as coded messaging I like
the stock became a shth to Signal
commitment to the cause of moas next
slide Gil read the room and wisely
pieced out while he continued to
participate in the scene at an arms
length tweeting vague nonsense mostly in
the the form of movie clips the length
of that arm grew longer and longer as
Apes grew increasingly disconnected from
reality realizing that he was being
elected to the role of cult leader that
anything he said any company he
commented on would be baked and decoded
as directions for the Apes to take
action on and that such a position posed
a substantial threat to both his
Newfound wealth and his personal safety
should he fall a foul of either the SEC
or the Apes themselves in late June of
21 he unplugged his social media
entirely and disappeared from the public
eye next slide Gil has been
retroactively recruited into every twist
and turn in the evolving ape lore
everything that Apes convinced
themselves about naked shorts married
puts the importance of failures to
deliver the need to DRS has been imposed
on Gil In Absentia here for example is a
post from May 2023 just shy of two full
years after Keith's last last public
post that outright advocates for
conspiratorial baking refine your tin
foil until it is pure gold and assumes
absolute homogeneity between Keith's
thesis and their own which is to say
that this poster believes dfv believes
what they believe next Slide the poster
signs off of course with follow the
White Rabbit next slide although he
almost certainly sold most if not all of
his stake in GameStop and rode off into
early retirement to raise his family
Apes remain convinced that he's still
out there hodling to this day cheering
them on from afar if not guiding them
from the Shadows via Reddit
Awards can you can you verify that
that's a thing like can I can I prove
that that like DRS works yeah well I
mean DRS has never been disproven we
just got to you know we just got to
trust the plan one of the things that
gets litigated repeatedly in all of this
mess is the definition of what makes a
meme stock I've actually got a
conspiracy Laden email in my inbox that
hinges off this in January 2021 there
was no such thing as a meme stock
despite the SEC itself putting out a
report where they directly state that
price movement was not related to shorts
closing there continues to be no
definition of what a meme stock really
is however examples of meme Securities
apparently include gme AMC and
bbby the term mem stock in reference to
gme seems like a tactical decision to
deride gme investors without directly
singling out a single company
ostensively in order to avoid bringing
more attention to the company whose
success is immediately threatening to
financial institutions on one hand mem
stock is basically the new name for
stock that behave like penny stocks even
if they aren't penny stocks which is
useful to a degree and on the other hand
is an attempt at identifying the why of
meme stocks via a definition Bed Bath
and Beyond in an April 2023 Court filing
lists a couple of characteristics of a
meme stock and why they felt it applied
to them the two characteristics that
they identify are a general Narrative of
an imperil company and Nostalgia value
that's kind of a workable definition but
to cut through the noise part of the
problem with trying to pin down what a
meme stock is is that it's changed a
meme stock in 20203 isn't the same
substance as a meme stock in 2021 the
original meme stocks in the fall of 2020
AMC Nokia GameStop Blackberry are
defined by a gleeful contrarianism it's
not that there's a narrative of a
company in trouble though that is
present in some cases and it's not the
Nostalgia value though that's also
somewhat present too those were not the
leading motives what made a meme stock
in 2020 is that aggressively publicly
buying a stock in a failing company past
its relevance is funny the thing that
truly separates a meme stock from every
other garbage ticker is that the active
buying in and of itself becomes the meme
a combination of absurdest performance
and inherently gamified exercise in 2023
though that wave has crested and broken
the joke is over but the investors are
still around and as we'll see the
gleeful contrarianism is gone replaced
with stoneface dedication to a perceived
cause so what is a mem stock it's a
stock whose play rests entirely on a
concocted narrative of a storied
American company under assault that
serves as a proxy Battleground for the
fate of the American economy The Vessel
through which the True Believers will
manifest their apocalypse and rebirth
the world into a golden age it is a
stock that is a candidate for moas while
any stock with a high short interest
potentially meets this criteria
ultimately three businesses would rise
to the top to become the Canon meme
stocks GameStop AMC Theaters and Bed
Bath and Beyond now companies tend to
have high short interest because they're
in bad shape declining market share
lackluster product poor reputation
loaded with debt and probably the number
one reason they're unprofitable and not
making money so it's important to note
that the self- selection process here
the thought process created by the
theory of moas is going to intrinsically
lead Apes to invest in bad companies
yeah so I've thought about putting one
of these together uh I've thought about
writing a DD I mean like check out all
of these Awards you get it's pretty long
you know but like that's good that's
good right like the longer it is the
more uh the more due the diligence
following the vote the Apes were faced
with their own fork in the road either
they accept the results of their own
test and acknowledge the prospect that
they made a mistake or they preheat the
oven and prepare to bake justifications
for why the overvote didn't occur you
don't need to be told which way they
went after the June 2021 shareholder
meeting there was a seismic shift in the
tone of super ston the goal post shifted
and damage control was engaged
immediately it began to circulate that
an overvote was never going to be
unveiled by the meeting and it was in
fact foolish to expect it to conspiracy
theories formed to explain the lack of
evidence of the conspiracy theory some
Apes were prevented from voting Brokers
normalize their vote counts before
providing them to GameStop GameStop
isn't allowed to admit the overvote
occurred whatever explains away the
negative test result the previous months
of research became shockingly malleable
being Rewritten the instant It produced
an unfavorable result and within a few
months history had just been straight up
Rewritten the experiment did demonstrate
the overvote but nothing came of it this
is ape research and it's worth an
examination in its own right due
diligence is the process of gathering a
folio of data on a potential investment
that explores the whole package the
company's financials the state of their
competition likely technological or
societal changes in the near future that
could impact the course of the company
for better or worse how many people on
the planet even theoretically want their
product it can get as intense as hiring
someone to drive out into the woods just
to make sure a mine actually exists
because this is a real thing real
investors do with a fancy sounding name
it quickly became an entire genre of
post on ape forums there is a delicate
line for us to walk here learning and
collaboration are good I would love to
stand here and tell you that Apes came
together and taught themselves how to
invest and better each other's lives
it's a great story indeed that's how the
Apes tell it but this is not that this
is something very different making money
on the stock market isn't difficult a
fish can do it no one going long on
biotech has a plan but Apes don't want
portfolios that outperform the market
they want to manufacture events that
[__] financial institutions while
flipping off regulators so ape due
diligence or DD for short
is rough it is mythology cloaked in the
veil of research at the base layer the
first generation of Apes have self-
selected as victims of a pump and dump
it's a bad starting point because these
people have demonstrated a lack of
familiarity with the subject matter and
poor judgment like a lot of victims of
stock scams many of them were denied a
good education and many have a poor
grasp of English as as a collective
group they were weaned on Keith Gill's
YouTube channel daily discussion threads
on Wall Street bets and very simple
rhetorical signals that's the kind of
material they're trained to take in and
they still largely took it in by
declaring I'm just a smooth brained ape
can someone with a few wrinkles explain
if my tits should be jacked rhetoric and
the broad Strokes are what matter you
need to understand that shorts never
closed you got a book rather than plan
and you need to hate Ken Griffin with
every atom of your being but
paradoxically Apes sincere L believe
they are collectively the Michael bur in
a sequel to The Big Short that has yet
to be written so while the details are
irrelevant they are driven to not just
research but produce their own original
research the majority of this early
semal DD was written by Apes who joined
the community well after January many
being verifiable bag holders people who
would be writing essays on Securities
fraud within 2 weeks of making their
first trade we know know this because
the authors will just flat out say it
posts will often open with a short
summary of why the author shouldn't be
trusted they will often admit that they
barely understand the documents they're
paraphrasing but have attempted it
anyway for the benefit of the community
the pitfalls are obvious like your
standard breed of crackpot apes are
educating themselves to specifically
solve a big problem they are pursuing
their chicken tender
when they skipped the first three
textbooks on finance and went straight
to short squeezing Melvin Capital they
skipped over some fundamentals but you
won't find Ken Griffin's secret strategy
in an Open Access course on risk
management rather than backtrack Apes
forged ahead into increasingly complex
and obtuse material looking for the
truth like some of the crap we had to
read furthermore the lender is being
asked to accept a new type of security
interest not the simple pledge but one
with which perforce has to be a security
interest in intangible property the
history of developing new security
interests in purely intangible property
is one that might give pause to even
that Rara Avis the adventuresome lender
when dealing with documents this intense
written by and for professionals the
only way a Layman can deal with it is
through decoding techniques you pull out
a fragment of a lecture or thesis that
you can make sense of and treat it as
the diamond in the roughed the rest is
interpreted through speculation Rippling
out from that fragment it's a very
unsound way to approach research and
these people then immediately present to
the class analogy is a favorite of the
ape author analogy in Academia is used
to bolster the substance but since the
Apes were introduced to these ideas
through the big short analogies are
loadbearing essentially using the same
language as Maro Robbie but you're
expected to to act on it it's not just
lightly informative entertainment it is
in fact Financial advice if the rocket
is launched without preparation it will
bring down the whole [__] base while
the small explosives are going off and
smaller players are going under gme will
have a lot more volatility the powers
that be will try to dampen that
volatility as much as possible since
even a small ignition could set this
[__] off I believe the plan is to do
controlled detonations until gme is the
only explosive left to set on off
Computer Share Works a bit like a heat
lamp and what that actually means is an
exercise for the reader their thought
process is so shamefully reverse
engineered that they need to make a joke
out of the confirmation bias just to
guard against that very real criticism
an unbelievable amount of their primary
sources for the mechanics of clearing
and settlement come from random emails
to the SEC from 2003 like even if you
presume that that material is accurate
consider all the obvious ways that a
public comment on an upcoming piece of
legislation could be unreliable 20 years
after the legislation has been
introduced that is how you get the Apes
frothing over long retired systems they
jumped in a time machine from the 2020s
back to 2004 when we had the last
hysteria about naked Short Selling which
itself was built off a half-baked
understanding of the subject from the80s
this
leaves gaps the result of all of this is
a truly spectacular rate of generational
decay in the Apes Collective
understanding of the thing they have
devoted their lives to understanding
despite becoming an increasingly
ambitious Ploy moas devolved into an
incredibly simple scheme in just a few
weeks you just buy GameStop shares and
hold until moas and the infinity pool
will ensure you become a gillionaire
apdd can only only function to reproduce
existing ideas or developed new
mythology in reaction to new issues even
the papers that look like they're doing
the math boil down to buy and hold it's
a bad practice to cite a date or price
for moas so the only accepted values are
soon and infinite and all of this is
regulated by the mechanism of social
media some of this may be evoking
memories of konon and while the overlap
between the two movements is non-trivial
for the most most part it is simply that
as a social mediad driven phenomenon its
ideas are shaped by populism and reddits
algorithm DD that the community approves
of is showered with Reddit Awards praise
and clout so there's an incentive
emotional and in some cases monetary to
you know have more DD adab bit was a
late arrival to the squeeze the
account's first post was on the 10th of
March and by the 14th he posted his
first amateur sec Securities fraud essay
by April 22nd he posted the first in a
series called House of Cards that Apes
pumped to the point that it was
temporarily the top post on Reddit and
naturally it is almost entirely gawking
at emails from 2003 adabat was conferred
a level of status that would see him
named alongside the queen Kong herself
as among the movement's most prestigious
thinkers he became something of an
influencer complete with his own
perpetual unfinished magnum opus which
tragically we will never get he didn't
acquire this reputation through good
work he did that by giving the Apes what
they wanted for DD to be accepted it
needs to be simple it can be long but
the whole thing needs to be fully
summarized in 100 words Max because the
most important thing is that it needs to
reinforce the existing belief system and
no one will read your DD if you don't
tell them you agree with them at the
outset all of this is enforced through
the upvote button DD that meets the
community's criteria gets elevated DD
that muddies the water or Worse spreads
fear uncertainty and doubt is
aggressively suppressed regardless of
the rigor of any individual essay this
is Academia via populism it is the ideal
circumstances for critical thought to be
suspended the Apes get to pick and
choose what facts shape their thesis and
in doing so
they create mythology this is why the
moas theory can stand tall on a
foundation of sand and Vapor the actual
mechanics are interchangeable initially
they misunderstood how 140% short
interest could occur that led them to
the stock borrow program and while it
proved their original Theory wrong it
gave them a better alternative so even
though the stock borrow program is baked
into the core thesis it doesn't matter
they can substitute it with half a dozen
different things the failure of the
overvote just proves how rigged the
system truly is each theory is just a
stepping stone to the next they can
never be proven wrong if they never sit
still long enough for someone to debunk
them real due diligence is as much an
argument to stay away from an investment
as it is an argument to buy in good due
diligence will argue the worst case
scenario what if things go completely
wrong what if a new product just sucks
ass and no one wants it can the company
weather bad news or will it fold in half
AP DD exists to keep moas alive as time
went on decoding became a more and more
explicit form of DD this started
innocently enough initially Keith Gil
Ryan Cohen and Michael bur were
subtweeting Apes very explicitly whether
it was Ryan Cohen's official statements
thanking retail investors for their
support or Gil communicating with Apes
through gifts these were thinly veiled
messages to Apes but they weren't
substantive there was not a deep meaning
to Ryan Cohen tweeting a fist Emoji or
reposting an ape meme about himself but
this normalized the idea that these
figures communicated with Apes through
secret messages and since these guys
were never available to clarify or
disprove theories it cultivated decoding
techniques that grew more and
more ambitious dfv roaring Kitty tweet
deciphered
1627 has to do with naked shorting
options derivative cases which ties
directly in which SEC rule 10
B-21 can you explain the connection just
so my dumb ass can follow all I'm coming
up with is a couple of legal cases
beyond that I don't know are we saying
this painting is from
1627 this painting is from a West
Anderson movie but the Roman numeral on
the right side is for 1627 how's that
tied to naked shorting GM Rick and Morty
how the show might be hinting at us
about the financial system and the
collapse of Citadel via their own greed
this is how the 1% sees us candidly I've
have seen no evidence so-called fake or
synthetic shares exist but many of you
disagree I love it basically saying who
am I to say the hedge funds are creating
shares out of thin air I guess we'll
just pull back the curtain to see Adam
Aaron saying there's no evidence of
synthetics is act
genius just think about it when he does
pounce they can't go after him for
Market manipulation because he'll have
evidence of the exact opposite to a
person with autism words mean something
every word does every symbol every
Unwritten suggestive wink or nudge we're
really good at giving Clues and seeing
deeper meaning I say we because I have
Asbergers we notice patterns and
algorithms that normal people don't and
cryp language is often our bread and
butter yes dfb MJ bur even Papa Cohen
are communicating with Apes the only way
they can through cryptic means and their
messages are important remember every
word means something to an artist no
surprise that by June Keith Gill stopped
tweeting Al together it got to the point
where AMC CEO Adam Aaron dropped his
phone and tweeted out a single M and
apes became fixated on decoding it
despite Aaron's efforts to dispel the
fervor Aaron's statements just fed into
the idea that the M was significant
yesterday I tweeted an M by mistake but
many of you thought I was being less
than candid in the denial and that the M
must have meant something nope just a
tweeting error but today I am tweeting
this and it does mean something why
question for the 10
foils why did he leave that much space
what is it 10 between text and why I
think it's
11 can't figure it out Ryan Cohen the
chairman of the board of GameStop took
one photo with notorious corporate
Raider Carl iin the guy Oliver Stone
based Gordon greed is good gecko off of
in 1987 which immediately cast iin as a
savior figure in dozens and dozens of
DDS as conspiratorial techniques like
this became more popular and more
dominant on these boards the line
between vetted DD and speculation began
to blur now the solid afdd was already
built on the same Foundation of sand as
outright speculation but there was still
a clear shift over time after the failed
shareholder vote naturally more and more
radical explanations were required all
of these exist to answer the same
question where's the evidence of the
fake share
why aren't we seeing the answer we
expect to see the answer is almost
always that the debt or shares were
shifted into some new form previously
unknown to Apes since the ape
understanding of the market is rooted
very firmly in the realm of Googling
wrinkle brain explains short squeeze
that is most things so we start to see
more and more out their instruments
being introduced they start talking
about dark pools options ETFs and so on
folding that material in more and more
pure thesis based on the naked short
conspiracy maintaining a stable
community built entirely out of
conspiracy in security and resentment is
tricky to get them through this Apes
police sentiment like few others even
crypto a product wholly at the mercy of
sentiment is more tolerant of bad news
than Apes because they are nominally
willing to engage with reality as it
exists they'll spin bad news like the
collapse of FTX as good for the
ecosystem as a whole pretending that
it's calling out Bad actors but they
don't deny that FTX has gone sour since
moas is basically a fantasy untethered
from any real business fundamentals the
reasons to not buy in get longer and
longer as time goes on and so the
restrictions on what is and isn't
permissible to talk about also grow
longer and longer moas is when you break
it down Market manipulation via the
prisoners dilemma the big theoretical
payout only works if literally everyone
holds the line but simultaneously
everyone involved has both the personal
incentive and ample opportunity to screw
over the others and knows that everyone
else has that same opportunity it is a
philosophy that demands extremely strict
Orthodoxy you buy and you hold
discussing exit strategy is derided as
price anchoring remember remember the
gains are not theoretically infinite
they are literally infinite this leads
directly to unhinged memes about apes
becoming gillion from selling one single
share it leads to stories about the
post-mass world where apes don't
actually need to sell any shares at all
ever they just live off the dividends
from Gamestop for the rest of their
lives and for the lives of their
children and their children's children a
future where one single share confers
wife change generational wealth sharp
eared listeners may have noticed that I
said dividend in there and they may be
asking The Logical follow-up question
where does the money for these dividends
come from don't worry about it in fact
why are you so concerned with what other
people do with their money are you just
here to spread fud and undermine gme I'm
just an individual investor who likes
the stock and the company that is debt
free and cash flow positive backed by an
unprecedented movement from shareholders
to direct register their shares in order
to combat corruption in the dtcc fud is
is literally anything that casts any
amount of Doubt on any part of the plan
I don't believe that GameStop will be
worth an unlimited amount of money per
share that doesn't seem
possible why wouldn't the price Peak and
then come back
down I should probably set an exit
threshold because I'm pretty sure other
people are going to be selling too and I
don't want to miss the
opportunity no but for real where does
the money for these dividends come
from direct registration mutated
extremely quickly from an attempt at
proving the existence of concrete crimes
with objective numbers a thing it failed
to do into a loyalty ritual a spell that
if executed correctly would create the
conditions that would allow moas to
happen a specific Quirk of The Narrative
of moas the idea that the apes are
engaged in a phantom war with the short
hedge funds leads to various delusional
but logically consistent outcomes like
the belief that any anyone who is not on
board with the play is a hired agent of
the opposition the rubber neckers
mocking Apes on r/g meltdown aren't
merely trolls contrarians or naysayers
but hired shills planted in a
communities as part of an elaborate
sciops to undermine them and convince
them to sell their shares so that the
shorts can cover which is of course
predicated on the belief that there's no
real shares available which is
predicated on the belief that there's
some truly unfathomable amount of
undetectable naked shorts which etc etc
etc this is a clever word inversion an
actual shill is someone who stands off
to the side of a grift and acts as an
unrelated hype man they posture as just
a random independent passer by while
actually having an undisclosed interest
in the thing that they are helping to
sell a shill wants you to buy something
naturally super ston and the other
derivative forums are deeply infested
with shills literally telling people to
buy and promoting the virtue of never
ever selling for any reason ever here's
a DD post literally structured for
recruitment from reddit's Front Page the
reason the DD posts have so many awards
is because Apes believe they could abuse
the system to Shield gme to r/ all
they're not coordinating though they're
all just individual investors coming to
their own conclusions about what to do
with their Reddit Awards in light of the
community being 98% Shilling by volume
it became culturally expedient to
redefine the word so that all the shills
would stop being accurately called
shills so in ape circles a shill is any
unbeliever predictably this Arrangement
where anyone who isn't frothing
committed to the cause is a hired shill
Fosters an erir of paranoia and has a
rather extreme chilling effect on the
idea of you know asking very reasonable
questions that would be extremely normal
in any other investment Forum this
paranoia extends to policing maintenance
of the illusion that this is all just an
organic uncoordinated series of
individual decisions everyone's like I
want to make a lot of money let me do a
bunch of research they're like hey
here's what I found out everyone's like
yeah me too yeah me too yeah me too yeah
and then like we realized oh crap all of
our predictions we made as a group
individually then as a group confirmed
and vetted and and picked apart and the
best Rose to top and and that's how you
get
research it's like the perfect
experiment this feeds both the narrative
that their behavior is not a mass
hypnosis but is instead the product of
genuine rigor and this has the added
bonus of providing a basis to deter
accusations of Market manipulation now
while it's true that it's unlikely that
we'll see a RICO filed with 20,000 John
Doe defendants Apes seem aware that
they're playing close to the fire they
are looking to collectively engineer an
artificial price movement which would
absolutely get you in trouble if you did
it solo so they lean into the
decentralized nature of the movement as
best they can and it's it's very funny
edit two removed some Weis Etc from my
exit strategy after concerns were raised
that phrasing my exit strategy like I
originally did might be construed as
attempted Market manipulation in the end
anyone reading this is just an
individual ape doing whatever they want
with their own money users will encant
this is not Financial advice and I just
like the stock with the same energy as
no copyright infringement intended in
the description of a complete upload of
Dances with Wolves to YouTube it's not
Financial advice not legal advice for
entertainment educational purposes only
anything I say my opinion please don't
make any financial decision based on
anything I say in these videos that
being said hit the like button subscribe
button all YouTube algum stuff so you
get the videos I put them out see I'm
think see man last night dat I tell
every day the day they released us is
false give false narrative Market we can
make bad trade
listen so the point is GameStop is
operating smarter than ever before and
that's what people just don't understand
yet that's the public eye just doesn't
see and it's because of all the
mainstream media fud and that's just why
I think the mother of all short squeezes
is inevitable of course this is just my
opinion you literally should take my
opinion with a grain of salt I'm telling
you a stock is going to go way up
because a lot of people like it and I'm
just a guy on the internet why would you
believe me they don't collude instead
there's an abstract infinity pool that
happens to describe the abstract Notions
of shares that will never be sold it
speaks to their insecurity on whether
they're safe to be doing this and that
concern is probably well founded because
sure the US government wrote off the gme
squeeze as a one-off viral event and let
everyone off the hook but if the Apes
get their wish and really do
deliberately risk collapsing the us or
global economy after several years of
organizing yeah I think the US federal
government would sooner make that Rico
filing than give usop AOS literally
billions of dollars for his shares in
GameStop the whole of ape culture is
persuasive in no small part because of
how it plays off existing social
anxieties we are collectively primed for
these narratives by a complicated soup
of messages a combination of distrust in
financial institutions married with a
mythologization of the stock market and
a financial reality of stagnant wages
and greed flation that make it feel like
playing the market is the only possible
way to build any kind of wealth or
comfort and that's just the stuff that's
rooted in reality ape motivations are
ultimately pretty simple their lore is
complex but their reasons are not
they're gambling addicts who are starved
for social attention the whole mem stock
ecosystem actually makes a ton of sense
for why it's as motivating as it is
since it combines all the addictive
highs of gambling with all the energy of
a soap opera every day there's something
new there's the constant drama of the
price action ups and downs though mostly
Downs if it's not price action then it's
new theories new DD new moderator drama
it's very easy to compartmentalize as
entertainment to forget what's at stake
is you know the family finances money is
really easy to abstract away at the best
of times and it only gets easier when
it's produced and gamified and when so
much of it is irony poisoned performance
apps like Robin Hood have already come
under criticism for their gamification
of playing the market but even if that
weren't a factor the apes are more than
happy to gamify things for one another
and frame everything in the language of
video games the language of boss fights
grinding and completionism that's
already addictive and it just upgrades
to weapons grade bad times when combined
with consp sporal mindsets and the
attendant narcissism paranoia and
overconfidence Gordon Penny cook an
associate professor at the University of
Regina in his pre-publication paper
overconfidently conspiratorial argues
that the actual defining trait of the
conspiratorially minded isn't narcissism
or a need to feel special though those
are observably common traits in
conspiracy circles but excessive
overconfidence this is anecdotally
intuitive to anyone who is significant
time in conspiracy circles but it is
this overconfidence that leads to the
refusal to re-evaluate beliefs the
assumption that they accurately
understand complicated systems better
than others and this is to me the most
interesting claim of the paper a
counterintuitive belief that their
opinion is in fact in the majority the
entire thing with Apes policing negative
sentiment is actually a pretty good
example of that in the way that they
have an itchy trigger finger for calling
any anyone even longtime DD writers a
paid shill if they say anything negative
or disagree with a favored theory in the
ape mind the only possible reason to
express doubt that GameStop is being
attacked by short sellers who are trying
to kill the company in order to prevent
moas is because you're being paid to the
ape thesis is to them so self-evident so
persuasive that it's just common sense
everyone already believes it in
inevitably this leads to Pinnacle Echo
chamber Behavior no one outside the
bubble can be trusted anyone talking
about apes is engaging in psychological
warfare to wear Apes down because why
else would you care about apes or find
this interesting or newsworthy the
inevitable synthesis of this thinking is
a warped worldview where companies no
longer go out of business for any reason
other than targeted destruction Sears
blockbusters Toys R Us hell Enron get
retroactively cast as the victims of
short sellers this is a lens on the
world necessary to recast ape Behavior
their quest for infinite wealth not as
self-serving greed but as
altruism virtue has been a part of the
rhetoric since the GameStop squeeze
itself investors were engaged to buy and
hold to get revenge for 2008 and finally
let the little guy have his fair share
we won't say that people didn't
genuinely believe that but you can
imagine how useful that narrative would
be to convince Apes to hold while you
personally divest your entire stake at
$400 a share the continuing escalation
of the antagonism of Wall Street has fed
the ape's sense of morality they are
very much the good guys who are saving
the world by holding shares in GameStop
but at the same time they have you know
ulterior motives they want destructive
amounts of money money they do that vile
thing where every share is a tribute to
certain deceased individuals you know a
tribute that involves doing the thing
that they already wanted to do hold
GameStop shares
sandwich this is a tribute to my grandpa
rest in peace
Jack this creates fascinating and
harrowing conflicts in the ape mindset
some apes are here just for the money
and find the activism or philanthropic
elements to be cring worthy but in the
fiction they are literally involved in
an invisible war against the most
powerful entities on the planet and are
so in order to free us from our
oppression when they take the Reigns of
the economy they are going to do it
right and be just sovereigns it's a
full-blown savior complex we will make
the world better whether it be locally
Statewide nationally or globally we are
here to fix the world that Wall Street
and the the bad Boomers broke we will
use our attendees for good and perhaps
get a Lambo in the process or in my case
a [__] cyber truck but at the
same time they see the immense payout of
moas as the reward for the tribulations
they have endured billions of dollars in
remuneration for the disappointed side
eyes they catch at family gatherings
they resent the fact that no one takes
them seriously and their philanthropy
exists in ttention with a very intent
urge to rub all our noses in it when
they're eventually proven right because
we all had our chance beyond the toys
you're going to buy who are you going to
help that's what matters because there
are plenty of people to help now you
can't help everybody you can't go save
everybody from working a 9 to5 they had
their chance okay they could have got in
they could have done their DD they could
have done their research we tried to
tell them over dinner they didn't listen
whatever had their chance okay because
apes are so disconnected from actual
fact reality has been happy to to
deliver them an endless supply of great
disappointments week after week after
week of failed catalysts missed hype
dates deconstructed gamma ramps and
falling stock price as the stock price
of these unprofitable companies
continues to decline from their short
squeeze Peaks it's just it's kind of
really really funny to watch this mass
of people so deeply convinced that a
drop in the value of GameStop is a
direct attack on them when Gamestop is
currently valued well above even their
most profitable years ever as with any
other apocalyptic belief placed under
cognitive strain this leads to
aggressive fragmentation one group says
that DRS is the way but Apes just
haven't been doing it properly and an
argument breaks out about plan accounts
versus book accounts another group says
that plan versus book doesn't matter all
that matters is Apes need to DRS harder
both groups accuse the other of being
paid Shield employed to distract
fragment and mislead the community a lat
game DD theory is the belief in a
turnaround play that moas won't happen
per se but Bed Bath and Beyond or
GameStop or hilariously some speculative
merger of the two will achieve moas like
valuations based entirely off strong
fundamentals and the moas is irrelevant
because what GameStop is building is a
great company gme purists hold to a pure
form of moas that's firmly rooted in
spiritual loyalty to GameStop which
rapidly turned into a spiritual loyalty
to Ryan Cohen yeah I didn't I mean I
didn't actually buy until March but you
know I was reading the DD then you know
Ryan Cohen he makes this play into Bed
Bath and Beyond and everybody on the
boards just gets like super hype about
it and uh and yeah like anything the man
touches is gold like he's he's a king
maker he's the book King so who is Ryan
Co Cohen Ryan Cohen is a board
billionaire who fancies himself an
activist investor and a fixer of failing
companies he made his money selling the
online petf food store chewy.com to
PetSmart which he founded with a
combination of venture capital and
Daddy's Money the official story of
chewy admits that they didn't get
outside investment until 2013 but they
hired a bunch of Executives from Amazon
and PetSmart right out the gate and
those suckers aren't cheap so logical
deduction is that you know there was
already some money there next slide
please Ryan Cohen ran chewy as a tech
company burning venture capital and
running at a loss until they were bought
out for 3.35 billion in
2017 when the company went public in
2019 the company disclosed a $268
million loss for fiscal year 2018
Cohen's final year as CEO next slide in
September 2020 as the mem stock wave was
gaining steam he disclosed that he held
a 10% stake in GameStop believing that
the company could be turned around Cohen
wrote an open letter to the GameStop
board board in November proclaiming his
immense faith in GameStop's potential if
they would only take his advice on
Thursday December 17th 2020 he increased
his stake to
12.9% all three of these events were
Catalyst for gme in August GameStop was
trading below $5 by the end of the year
it would be around 19 next slide please
an activist investor is an investor who
buys stock off the open market and then
throws their weight around and tries to
take an active role in the running of
the company to despite the fact that
they didn't actually give any money to
the company NeXT slide on January 11th
2021 it was announced that Cohen would
join GameStop's board of directors and
then in April Cohen was made the
chairman Cohen made bold Promises of a
transformation into the Amazon of gaming
next slide please objectively Ryan Cohen
isn't good at actually running companies
or generating shareholder value
GameStop's turnaround has resulted in a
large amount of capital wasted on
fulfillment centers that were closed
shortly thereafter a further retraction
of the company from their Global
operations and the launch of an nft
Marketplace the company describes in its
10K annual report as quote not material
to the Consolidated financial statements
for fiscal 2022 next slide Ryan Cohen's
one material impact on any business he's
involved in as an activist investor is
that he is followed by Apes who based on
his limited role in the January 2021 run
have elevated him to a Messianic role
believing that he is working behind the
scenes to engineer moas and thus follow
his Investments next slide this
irrationally passionate fan base has
succeeded in keeping GameStop hovering
at an absurd valuation well above the
company's actual financial performance
but they're also highly annoying a
burden for management to deal with and a
possible threat to employees so what I'm
going to do right now is I'm going to go
to this store here and ask if they are
hiring let's see what they what they say
that's Ryan Cohan uh strategy yeah I
like the guy I don't know if you like
him but I I like him so much you know
who I'm talking are you really
interested in you know who I'm talking
about right no you never heard about
Ryan Cohen there Rings a name rings a
bell that if you're working in GameStop
that name should ring everything it's
too early see so right now what i notic
is a lot of layoffs in Bed Bath and
Beyond and a lot of recruiting
aggressively recruiting people in
GameStop yeah most likely there will be
a merger between GameStop and Bed Bath
and Beyond wow into a bigger company I
don't even know how that works because
GameStop sells games Bed Bath and Beyond
the whole the whole thing is going to
change all right
so that's the plan so
GameStop is merging with Bed Bath and
Beyond and Ryan Gohan he's not joking
he's not sitting as a chairman in
this company GameStop playing with his
balls no he's not he is hiring
aggressively hiring retail people and
the merger is coming when the only one
who knows this answer is Ryan Cohen Apes
have taken to decoding any in all
communication from Cohen for any
coincidences that they can point to as
indications that he is doing what they
claim he is because it would be very bad
news for Apes if he were in fact just
some rich loser who enjoys the attention
next slide please no one wants to work
with him given the poor material
performance of GameStop relative to its
inflated Share value retailers Bed Bath
and Beyond and Nordstrom both told him
to go take a hike after he attempted to
buy his way into Power you know really
at the end of the day the hedge funds
like they should have seen this coming
like they targeted Gamers you know we we
know what it means to just like grind a
boss fight and and like you know grind
reputation in uh in a video game and so
like you know locking the float uh we
can grind that out we know what that
takes uh dsing everything you know all
of it uh we we can do that compared to
GameStop and AMC companies with products
for kids and teens that at least have
some connection to the Nostalgia of
Youth Bed Bath and Beyond seems like a
curveball Until you realize that the
Apes just followed GameStop's savior to
his next project when Cohen first
disclosed his stake in bed bath the
resulting ape frenzy triggered bed
Bath's largest intraday percentage price
increase since its initial public
offering some investors bought in due to
uncritical zealotry towards Cohen or
belief that the bed bath play was a moas
master stroke others believed he would
genuinely rescue the company While
others just wanted to get in early on
the next pump and dump whatever ever the
specific reason we're only talking about
Bed Bath and Beyond because of Cohen
Cohen bought into bed bath because it
was a dying company he thought he could
save it's cut and dry likewise there is
no Nuance to bed Bath's troubles it's a
brick and mortar retailer that was
struggling for all the obvious reasons
already declining sales a failed pivot
to private label Goods the pandemic and
subsequent supply chain disruptions poor
relations with their vendors and a
disastrous stock buyback program loading
the company with debt created a ative
feedback loop where the company couldn't
stock its shelves the company reached
the point of allegedly turning off the
air conditioning to save money why Ryan
Cohen thought he could write this ship
is anyone's guess but it's fair to say
that he didn't have much tangible impact
one way or the other presumably he
intended to rapidly work his way up the
chain as he did with GameStop instead
the board resisted Cohen's influence and
within weeks Cohen and the company had
settled on an agreement to to prevent a
hostile takeover attempt Cohen was
fixated mainly on bed Bath's baby Supply
subsidiary by by baby insisting that
under the right circumstances baby could
be valued on a revenue multiple like
other e-commerce focused retailers and
justify a valuation of several billion
dollars the claim already loaded with
caveats was based on a years old
internal evaluation by bed bath and we
know now that it was pogash baby was
incapable of standing on its own without
these sub ization of Bed Bath supply
chain but this number is still cited by
Apes over a year later so in August he
decided to divest his interest in bed
bath but did so in a way that the kids
might call sus Cohen initially bought a
99.8% stake in the company which needs
to be disclosed via the filing of a
schedule 13d but in the time following
Cohen's purchase bed bath was in the
process of carrying out a share buyback
which reduced the number of outstanding
shares and increased Cohen's ownership
to
11.8% without him personally trading as
a seemingly irrelevant Preamble on
August 12th Cohen tweeted at least her
cart is full moon emoji in reply to a
scathing CNBC article about bed bath he
was required to update all the paperwork
on his ownership by the end of April
2022 but didn't file the necessary form
three indicating a 10% or greater
ownership until after the close of
trading on August 15th by now it should
be clear that Apes aren't very good at
all this so when they saw this they
either thought Cohen bought more shares
or that in concert with the Tweet he was
signaling them to buy more to fill up
their carts moon emoji on the following
morning before trading opens Cohen then
updates his schedule 13d to reflect the
new number Apes again see this as
bullish a and go crazy driving up a bed
bath share price by 70% over the course
of August 16th Cohen then submits a form
144 to the SEC stating that he hadn't
bought or sold any bed bath shares in
the last 3 months but was maybe
intending to after this submission Cohen
then divests himself of all of his bed
bath shares reportedly pocketing 68
million in profit on his initial
investment the form 144 stating Cohen's
intention to sell goes public the
following day on the 17th this spreads
Mass ape confusion finally on the 18th
amends the schedule 13d and form four to
reflect his sale of his bed bath shares
2 days earlier and that ends Cohen's
long-term involvement with bed bath
after about 9 months now whether this
constituted misconduct from Ryan Cohen
is not a question we can answer but it
is a question worth asking unfortunately
we may never get an answer because while
a lawsuit against Ryan Cohen on this
matter is ongoing it's a mess a
self-represented ape raced to the courts
in less than a week to file a class
action lawsuit that put forth an
unhinged account of this situation
according to the complaint Ryan Cohen
had been planning this from the
beginning as part of a conspiracy with
bed bath CFO who the complaint misnames
repeatedly and also JP Morgan was in on
it for some reason it's bad the
complaint is littered with factual
errors applies the wrong laws and is
just a train wreck from end to end the
case was wrestled off of the ape and an
amendment was submitted that looks like
this but there's only so much the new
team can do to alter the original
complaint so it's unlikely that anything
meaningful will come of it if a jury
were to find that Cohen's Behavior was a
deliberate effort to inject
misinformation into the market it would
be a textbook example of actual Market
manipulation it would be a situation in
which retail investors would be
compensated for damages caused by said
manipulation yet remarkably despite this
being a lawsuit focusing on giving the
Apes money the Loyalty of many of the
Apes remains with Cohen so they cheer
against the success of the class action
this is the end of Ryan Cohen's
involvement with Bed Bath and Beyond we
aren't aware of him so much as
mentioning it in the time since a
one-off interview in November of 22 you
know my My Views changed of the business
and ultimately I sold and yet rather
than Apes accepting what's just happened
to them that their supposed genius
activist investor who would make them
all rich lured them into buying shares
in a dying retailer Apes started to bake
the decoding goes up a whole new level
at this point there is absolutely no
communication from Cohen regarding Bed
Bath and Beyond so they need to both
uncover the secret messages and then
decode them Cohen said he was in bed
bath for the long term and then bailed
inside 9 months did he lie did he WAP
rapidly pivot when things didn't go his
way or was that initial statement always
intended to reassure Apes that he was in
on the play regardless of how it
appeared the myth quickly became that
Cohen didn't abandon the apes or give up
on bed bath instead Cohen had to work
from the Shadows to outmaneuver both the
bed bath board themselves who didn't
want anything to do with him and the
short sellers this is when we get that
Carl Iken tweet Apes took this to be
definitive evidence of a partnership
between Cohen and iin whose end game was
to merge GameStop and bed bath into a
competitor to Amazon Deal's already done
uh we still don't know where Ian son is
at um RC's yet to reveal himself Ian has
to be involved himself oh yeah look at
IEP falling man the timing of everything
man come on they like these people who
don't believe in this [__] they want to
try to psych you out and B Gaslight you
in the [__] but honestly man the
timeline matches up so honestly man I'm
taking I'm taking the gamble personally
so there it is and then and then in
November of 22 Cohen publishes a series
of children's books called Teddy these
are mediocre Pro capitalist paum
basically exactly what you'd expect from
a billionaire libertarian who was bored
out of his mind and desperate for the
approval of others Apes of course fired
up the industrial evens and got ready to
bake like they'd never baked before
Ryan's children's books are actually in
messages for us just look at those
titles China money running the world
words can't hurt you as in fud it's the
only way he can legally communicate with
us my daily tinfoil what's up with the
pattern on Teddy's signature shirt I
know people think these Easter eggs are
wrong but I believe the deal was closed
on the 10th Teddy day and the 13th
Teddy's belt buckle is when the filing
will drop also merger Monday China is an
anagram of I Teddy goes to China that
means Ryan has approached iin about a
lucrative partnership the books teach
literal children to not put all their
eggs in one basket which of course means
gme holders should also buy Bed Bath and
Beyond when it's 150 the clock hands
point to 10 and 2 which means that any
alignment of 10 2 12 1 and 50 become
valid readings of the Hidden code if you
save your money you can buy ice cream
which clearly means if you hold then you
get your treats which is another
signaling of tendies I want to be the
book King clearly he wants us booking
our shares General so's chicken
tokenized security offerings it was
rumored that Cohen was going to be
buying a steak in Alibaba the Amazon of
China but then also Cohen tweeted about
James Cameron's Titanic one of the most
popular and successful films in the
history of human existence and apes took
this as an obscure reference to a
potential announcement and wouldn't you
know it February 21th 10 2023 is both
National Teddy Bear Day and the
re-release of Titanic there are too many
coincidences this is it this is Teddy
day Ryan Cohen is going to be announcing
an acquisition of Bed Bath and Beyond
with his good friend China Reed iin
where he's going to spin off bye-bye
baby and merge with GameStop to form
gica exactly and the shills call it all
crazy conspiracy theories [__] RC
can't just come out and say oh hey guys
I'm working on an m&a deal with bye-bye
baby get ready to be rich on a
specifically called out date he said all
he could say through the books if you
are really patient one day you will have
money to eat all the ice cream you want
while taking care of your family and
friends so as I do it here and I and I
see it Guys these guys are expanding
their catalog but without throwing up
the
flare hey we're getting big bigger so
now what can happen for GameStop
GameStop can absorb Teddy at any time
and in verse they already have it all
set out the map is there he's been
building it in secret behind everyone
else and now you have a
partnership so let's take a moment to
marinate on this to consider just How
Far We've really come we've gone from
vaguely legitimate if poorly understood
and IL defined theories on Market
mechanics to staring at illustrations of
an old man fumbling a turkey in order to
extract coded Financial advice from the
patterns on his
shirt there's really only one way this
can
go it is a reality that businesses often
make poor decisions misdirecting company
resources to wasteful pet projects or
failing to adapt to changes in tastes
technology and Society so we've reached
a point where apes are convinced that
Ryan Cohen is going to swoop in and buy
out bed bath and beyond their evidence
for this is overwhelmingly based on
secret messages delivered to them via
literal children's books their grasp on
reality has totally frayed at this point
every bed bath statement was a coded
message all bad news was just to throw
off the short sellers this meant that
his bed bath continued to decline the
Apes looked at it with distrust and
confusion in January 2023 Bed Bath and
Beyond defaulted on a loan payment and
on February 1st they missed an interest
payment on three tranches of bonds this
is bad this is we are completely out of
money levels of bad in response to this
they were approached by a firm Hudson
Bay Capital Management who presented
them with a deal that was completely
insane the deal is commonly referred to
as death spiral financing and if Lucifer
appeared alongside Hudson Bay at that
moment and offered bed bath and
alternative deal it'd be the same these
deals are the last resort where the
investor will offer a shockingly small
amount of capital UPF front and in
exchange they get to decimate the stock
price to whatever extent is necessary
for them to earn their return a company
signing a deal like this is the
unambiguous signal that they've
exhausted every alternative the basic
arrangement of the deal is that Hudson
gets preferred convertible shares from
bed bath for a lump sum of money then
these preferred shares can be converted
into common shares that Hudson can
immediately sell on the open market with
the number of shares generated based on
the lump sum divided by the recent
average value of a share with a sweet
discount just to make sure that Hudson
always has a profit margin these are
called death spiral financing because
they're a recipe for massive share
dilution the financer buys preferred
shares for a fixed sum converts those
into a variable number of shares and
then dumps those shares onto the market
almost certainly lowering the share
price via dilution alone if not
compounding negative sentiment and
massacred investor confidence the share
price going down means that the next
preferred share they convert will
convert into even more common shares
which will further lower the price which
will convert the next block into even
more shares and over and over in a mere
6 and a half weeks Hudson more than
quadrupled the number of Bed Bath and
Beyond shares in existence Apes Diamond
handed buy at any cost irrationality
their stubbornness the very thing that
Apes tout as their secret weapon against
the hedgies is the exact thing Hudson
was counting on to turn their profit the
Grim irony is that apes are so
predictably irrational in their madeup
war against hedge funds and short
sellers that it leaves them open to all
manner of unique and awful exploitation
at the hands of hedge funds and short
sellers the irony is so deep you could
drown in it the capital Hudson Bay
offered was used to pay down debt there
was nothing left to fix any of the
structural problems with with the
business so the only thing the deal
bought them was time the Hudson Bay deal
was terminated after less than 2 months
as bed bath stock price fell under a
dollar and showed no signs of recovery
and through this the whole time Apes
denied that dilution was happening
denied that it was the cause of the
decline in the share price denied that
Hudson Bay Capital was the buyer mocked
the Wall Street journal's use of inside
sources familiar with the matter and
denied that Bed Bath and Beyond was even
in the precarious position that bed bath
was actively warning them of we need the
proceeds from the transactions to pay
our outstanding obligations under our
credit facilities and Senior notes and
to operate our business and we expect
that we will likely file for bankruptcy
protection if the transactions are not
consummated the issuance of the
Securities in this offering will
significantly dilute the ownership
interest of the existing holders of our
common stock trading in our Securities
is highly speculative and poses
substantial risks to invest ERS this is
the context in which heat lamp is
produced a conspiracy whose every
element is reverse engineered to offer a
semblance of Hope critically incurious
heat lamp is baseless speculation that
squares the circle and explains way the
continued failure of Apes to crash the
global economy after two full years okay
so so get this what if what if we assume
the computer share has an algorithm that
manages their operational efficiency and
this algor algorithm works like a heat
lamp in a diner the algorithm moves
shairs into the dtcc in anticipation of
imminent transactions so what Wall
Street is doing is rolling up a Bus full
of people into the parking lot the staff
start making hamburgers and putting them
under the heat lamp but wouldn't you
know the customers are all vegetarian
and I guess aren't hungry so now the
dtcc can borrow the hamburgers and use
them to create synthetic hamburgers
which can be used to cover citad El's
illegal hamburger sales and then return
the counterfeit hamburgers to the diner
as if they were the
originals The Perfect Crime but this
wasn't the part of heat lamp that made
it stick that hamburger metaphor was
buried inside a 5,000-word rant so
incoherent that we can't even pull any
usable sound bites it's just walls of
nonsense the author's prior attempts at
sharing this thesis had been met with
criticism and mockery resulting in
putting the threads in the trash so the
core of heat lamp is this beautiful
story of self-actualization as the ape
learned that has ideas are important and
deserve to be read no matter what anyone
tells him the bulk of heat lamp is
scathing accusations of censorship
through intimidation by the mods
claiming that this Banger of a DD is
being suppressed by the mods to protect
the interests of Computer Share and
therefore the interests of the enemy
it's full-blown McCarthy ISM and that
rhetoric is what Apes took from heat
lamp the ape influencers find themselves
more and more in the same dilemma as
conservative YouTubers who nurtured
fascist audiences they need to play to
the crowd or risk being turned on juring
the scripting of this video ad AIT one
of the key figures in the ape Community
who you've been seeing constantly
deleted his account in response to
harassment brought on by expressing
waving faith in the ability of Apes to
defeat Ken Griffin adab bit like so many
DD authors before him evolved into his
final form you/ deleted the soap opera
conspiracy twists and turns that's the
fun stuff the really Sinister element of
all of this is that it's not just
socially engaging it's addictive ape
forums are littered with statements and
sentiments that are stereotypical of
gambling addicts apes are constantly
talking about their plans to buy buy
more how they wish they could afford
more how they can't wait for their
paycheck so they can get more shares of
Bed Bath and Beyond they use contrarian
sentiment to justify their habit the
price goes down buy more the price goes
up buy more bad news buy more good news
buy more thanks for the tasty dip they
suppress the price I buy more out of
spite they hide their habit from friends
and family complain that Partners try to
limit how much GameStop they buy and
brag about going behind their Partners
backs they take money from friends and
family while talking up the college
degree worth of DD they found on Reddit
and pour it all into this slate of
poorly run companies that they believe
have been elected as the candidate for a
mythological short squeeze the entire
idea of dollar cost averaging an actual
investment strategy has been warped into
pure delusional cope of averaging down
as the stock price keeps plummeting in
their minds it's assur play so of course
it makes sense to lower your cost basis
and thus improve your return but even
then within the whole mythology of moas
if the stock is supposed to go to phone
book Numbers then it really doesn't
matter what your average was it's just
an exercise and sunk cost catching a
falling knife as for me after holding
from $350 to $40 price drops only get me
more excited every price drop is a
discount and another opportunity to buy
the performative aspect are irony
poisoned and insincere in a genuinely
sickening way a lot of the ape lore is
easily discarded by their podcasters and
DD authors because they ultimately know
it's not true the hype the tinfoil the
coincidences the wife changing money the
Lambos these are all the social
performances needed to maintain the
veneer wrapped around the pathetic core
of a gambling addiction whose only hope
for Recovery is recruitment it's the
justification and distancing the things
that need to be true in order for the
vast amounts of time energy and money
dumped into these shares to not be a
waste but Apes will still always keep
one foot grounded where they can say oh
of course Teddy day wasn't going to
happen that was just hype for fun the
thing that January 2021 demonstrated was
that the price can go to the moon for no
coherent sensible sane reason Beyond a
bunch of people on a forum willing into
existence by convincing enough other
people to believe and if it happened
once then maybe it can happen again but
that constant double think the constant
cognitive dissonance of hyping up
knowingly fake ideas purely to maintain
energy in a failing stock play to put on
an outward-facing performance to lure in
new participants because if you don't if
you Flinch if the irony armor cracks and
you admit out loud that you don't
actually believe believe then it all
falls apart reality becomes true and
then it definitely won't happen again
that takes a toll the illusion must be
defended at all costs because the
illusion is all there
[Music]
is
on April 23rd 20123 Bed Bath and Beyond
filed for chapter 11 bankruptcy despite
the Staggering dilution deal that the
company simply couldn't raise enough
Capital to get ahead of its debts most
of which were incurred in a stock
buyback program that only ended in late
20122 long after the start of the
company's decline over the course of May
and June they sold off the company peac
meal favorable lease obligations here a
building there inventory shelves desk
chairs computers basically anything a
price could be attached to was sold off
in the proceeds sent directly to their
creditors Apes of course willfully
immune to reality at this point consider
all of this to be bullish this would be
painful but necessary but when all was
said and done even if moas never
happened bed bath would still pay off
handsomely this was founded on
absolutely nothing rooted entirely in
word games based on theories that the
company failed to directly deny the
company itself had been warning them
since January that in the event of
bankruptcy holders of the common shares
would likely receive no recovery critics
who predicted that the Hudson de deal
would merely upgrade the company's
forced Liquidation in chapter 7 up to a
managed Liquidation in chapter 11 were
right and apes were wrong literally
nothing that Apes predicted came true
because they aligned themselves into a
movement that refused categorically to
accept reality as it exists trading
prices for our Securities May bear
little or no relationship to the actual
recovery if any by holders of our
Securities bankruptcy proceedings
plotted along and the mythological Ryan
Cohen reverse triangle merger Teddy Ikon
partnership nft dividend reward for
loyal shareholders never emerged in
early June the deadline for the stocking
horse bid kept getting kicked back a few
days at a time from the 1st to the 8th
to the 11th to the 13th since the
stocking horse bid sets the tempo for
further liquidations Rumors in reality
were that the bids submitted were all
relatively small grabs at specific
assets rather than any move for the
company itself and the compy wanted more
time behind the scenes to try and rustle
up a better offer Rumors in the ape
Universe were that the offers were in
fact so good that bed bath needed more
time to properly evaluate the true value
of complicated share forshare offerings
of GameStop and iin Enterprises LP for
bbby again ion's sole involvement in all
of this is that he let Ryan Cohen take a
photo with him the ACT ual stocking
horse bid selected on June 13th was
Overstock a $900 million company
offering 21.5 million for the company's
name logo website mobile app and
relevant databases chalk another W up
for the Wall Street Journal and there's
sources familiar with the matter finally
September 29th 2023 the company formerly
known as Bed Bath and Beyond cancelled
released and extinguished all shares in
the company those intangible legal
rights the actual thing shares represent
cease to to exist and you might hope
that that would be the end of all of
this but well you know it isn't see
there's always something to grasp on to
the shares may be legally void but it'll
take years for every last broker on
Earth to remove the worthless husks from
apes accounts because of boring reasons
like recordkeeping laws and just low
priority so that's years and years where
an Ever dwindling core of increasingly
entrenched bed bath Apes can hold out
hope that Ryan Cohen will swoop in and
gift them absurdly valuable shares in a
company that doesn't even exist the
apocalypse is always just one more day
away apes are in a lot of ways the
funhouse mirror version of the stock
market they're not anti-wall street
they're sere for Wall Street they want
to be Scrappy important Savvy Underdog
traders who saw an opportunity and
seized it they quote The Wolf of Wall
Street in the big short because that's
who they see see themselves as sure they
say they hate Wall Street but then they
spend all their free time obsessing over
funneling more and more of their money
into the stock market there's a desire
an instinct to try and tease Apes apart
from the rest of the stock market to
invalidate their approach as a
perversion of the market if not
something entirely separate it can be
said that the Apes aren't engaging with
stocks as an intangible signifier of a
claim to some percent of a company
but as a wholly distinct thing an
entirely abstract vessel of value given
the overlap between crypto apes and mem
stock Apes whether it's GameStop or
Dogecoin it's really the same behavior
an accurate criticism of the ape system
is that this Behavior entirely decouples
the price of the shares from the value
of the company to the point that
companies like Bed Bath and Beyond are
saying as much in their filings the ape
counter criticism is that this is just
how the stock market Market works that
they're just doing what the big players
do and this is a compelling conflict of
ideas because it's wrong but not
entirely wrong there is an argument to
be made that in one sense all stocks are
meme stocks that narrative and story are
the driving forces of the stock market
that talk of fundamentals is all lip
service that fundamentals only matter in
so far as they can be woven into the
story after all the whole exercise is a
game of trying to predict the future
trying to price in things that haven't
happened but you believe are going to
and that is really just complicated
storytelling both groups are telling a
story and just sort of lightly gesturing
at something external to the narrative
that justifies its conclusions in that
regard apes are in fact a reflection of
the system really the only major
difference is that the things they are
gesturing towards are not merely wishful
thinking based on suggestive data but
entirely confabulated nonsense nothing
in ape psychology is new addiction to
gambling the pressure of social control
we are all vulnerable to these in some
degree but when you get deep into these
places it takes on whole new forms apes
are as a result of their conflict with
reality particularly vulnerable to being
further targeted by confidence Men and
other grifters some of them grift the
Apes for low stake Fame and Prestige
some to wash their pet theories and gain
support for their political policies and
some for plain old hard cash it can be
difficult to have empathy for Apes
because frankly a lot of them suck they
are conspiratorially minded and thus
prone to all sorts of terrible beliefs
many of which dovetail into Express
anti-Semitism making them right for
recruitment into even more extreme
ideologies as addicts they regularly
make terrible decisions that hurt others
they talk often about stealing from
their spouses or at least hiding their
addictions as they spend all the money
in the shared account many are pro
profoundly unhappy in their
relationships joking through gritted
teeth about wife changing money and how
much they resent their partners of
course it's easy to see how that Mutual
resentment might form they lie they
steal they recruit relentlessly and they
insist that others simply fail to
recognize their Brilliance they stress
every relationship they are involved in
and routinely hurt their families with
their Reckless gambling it's no mystery
why the wife isn't too happy with them
these days these groups in mve movements
appeal to entitled personalities and the
entire structure of their psychology and
socialization is addictive and retentive
The Narrative of participation flatters
them it makes them Savvy important
forward-thinking investors who are
beating the system at its own game they
cannot leave quit or even mentally check
out because then they'll miss the window
of the next big play When the due
diligence and quantitative Theory are
made up out of mythological nothingness
it's easy even logical for the UPS
decides to be so overwhelmingly valuable
that any Behavior no matter how Craven
or irrational becomes permissible it's
tempting to see Apes in their full
performative hubris bragging about
buying the dip and thanking Ken for the
discount and think you know what they
brought this on themselves but no one
deserves to be exploited like this no
one deserves to get shaken down by
grifters to the point that they have no
other choice but to become grifters
themselves and shake down everyone else
around them no one deserves to have
their ego and security ground down to
the point that there's no Escape no
reason to step back and admit defeat no
reason to reflect ironically the biggest
winners in all of this have been hedge
funds sure Keith and a few others made
Bank off the GameStop run but half of
them gambled their gains away hedge
funds on the other hand have been able
to play against apes and their
predictable irrationality Melvin AP ate
dirt in 21 and closed up shop in 22 but
Citadel started using Wall Street bets
as a recruiting ground and Hudson Bay
made a tidy profit by assuming that Apes
wouldn't just buy and hold through
massive dilution but would outright
thank them for the tasty dip it is as a
phenomenon an incredibly fraught subject
for Regulators because just how do you
respond to this setting aside bigger
broader questions about what markets
even should be how do you respond in the
immediate term to a group of investors
with enough Collective inertia to move
prices but a fundamentally flawed
understanding of what they're even doing
the Grim irony of ape culture is that it
has the operative mechanisms of a
gambling addiction without actually
gambling see if it were a gamble if they
were truly betting on something then
there would be some actual odds of
winning Apes like to talk about high
risk and high reward as a coping mechan
mechanism as the mismanaged companies
they're betting on continue to slide out
of business but all framing devices like
that assume that the thing you're
betting on can actually happen but the
weakest team in the league can
theoretically pull out a dark horse run
and take the cup that's a high-risk High
reward bet Apes on the other hand with
their theories of moas with their
coincidences and icon secret reverse
triangle mergers with their fundamental
Mis understanding of how a short sale
even works they're sitting around a
blackjack table convincing each other
that there's a secret rule that if you
hit 31 then the dealer has to give you
their entire tray so hit me hit me hit
me hit
[Music]
me
wind it's
BL wind and the
CH for the record I have read the entire
United States Bankruptcy code written by
the 95th American Congress November 6
1978 it has given me an incredible
understanding how to factually interpret
information filed on craw given
understanding to previously omitted
information that I disregarded in the
past and I will be referencing United
States law to factually prove that Ryan
Cohen remains involved with this
company plus we clearly have figured out
the game these people are playing and
have their balls in a vice if it's not
this play we move on to the next the
honeyhole has been exposed it feels like
we're driving backwards really fast at a
wall and just before we hit it the
secret level in Ready Player 1 is going
to open up and let us pass by the entire
race and win the fact that so many
shills spend so much of their time
endlessly replying to us yelling at us
to explain what assets are left how
we're soon going to go to zero I've
never seen so many humans spend so much
of their time on something that doesn't
concern them and it's quite bullish the
short hedge fund's biggest mistake in my
opinion is they tried to burn this
company to the ground which they
succeeded but that's been a known move
all along by an activist investor know
your enemy now they are trapped in
bankruptcy court so now Apes can buy
really low and the upside is so high if
you like this prediction I also have a
free nft
giveaway